what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the pregame
[Applause]
start do not forget to subscribe to the
channel and ring that notification Bell
that we are going to be notified of my
daily videos as you guys already know if
you have watched how many Sarah if you
have watched two or more of our videos
then we have what Pearl beef what do we
have beef exactly
so guys make sure you hit that subscribe
button also guys a couple announcements
before we start the show the first thing
we're going to talk about is that we
have two clips channels just pearly
clips and pearl daily make sure you go
subscribe to both also guys we have four
membership tiers the first will allow
you to be a part of our live chat
tonight the second tier you get to see
are behind the scenes Vlogs and our
Discord if you want to see me freestyle
rap sign up for the second tier
um third tier you get to connect with me
on social media and fourth tier you get
a one-on-one call with me once a month
do you want to know how to get a million
subscribers in a year sign up for that
call also guys
um they took away my Instagram so go
follow that just pearly things one they
also took away my first second third and
fourth Tick Tock so go follow me on Tick
Tock just pearlythings.5 uh we are on
Rumble now so we have a couple um
interviews we did with uh Nick Fuentes
that couldn't be put on YouTube so make
sure you go subscribe or what do you say
follow on Rumble
um go subscribe to wife school we are
dropping an episode with Melanie King
this month she is going to be helping me
you know fix my fashion problems so
Melanie's going to help me with that
also guys we are doing a meet up this
Sunday
um 5 30 at flat iron Square in London
Bridge and we are bringing security so
no weird stuff um but yeah we are doing
a meet up in flat iron square and London
Bridge so if you're you're in London you
want to come meet us go to that also
guys um we are a network so this is the
jpt network and we do have two talents
so make sure you go subscribe to King
Richie's Channel um he does live shows
on the days that I'm not doing live
shows and Auntie Jenny she does a
podcast on Monday and Saturday she was
the woman that was on the Andrew Tate
the viral Andrew Tate interview that was
just you know spitting facts so make
sure you go subscribe to her Channel as
well we also have just pearly animations
which is an animation Channel
um
and also we have a thousand likes and we
will open up the chat so if you want the
chat to open up to everyone make sure
you like the video
and finally we have a couple special
guests on the panel that have traveled
all the way from America to be on the
panel so let's give them a round of
applause welcome Mountain King mediocre
tutorials and reviews welcome to the
show
feel free to introduce yourself
sure uh MTR much more affectionately
known as mediocretorials and reviews
just happy to be here it's been a long
time coming we did content not too long
ago so I'm happy to finally come down to
London and we can have a conversation so
shout out to everybody also we start I
forgot to say this you say your name
your age your relationship status and a
fun fact okay uh name MTR age I am 37.
um relationship status I am single for
the streets
[Music]
hey why not though Hey listen I built my
value I could street now all I want say
something about it all right and
um fun fact
um I mean I do YouTube full-time I think
that's a fun fact for a lot of people
um a lot of people I like to snowboard I
like to ski I like to do weird things
you know what I mean so let's do things
that aren't necessarily black there it
is yeah I step outside of that and just
do whatever the hell I want fair enough
yeah
I'm Melanie King I'm on YouTube I'm 41.
my relationship status is looking for a
husband and uh yeah what else am I
supposed your name your age your
relationship status and a fun fact also
oh tell them your channel you know oh
Melanie King you check me out with
Melanie King and um a fun fact about me
is
um that's a fun fact like I don't know
like
just what's a fun fact uh whatever you
factually do you want to do you want to
do you want to do the motivational
speakers yes yes I'm moving more into
motivational speaking and uh I'm so
proud of pearl that's a fun fact I'm
very happy to be here and I'm yeah and
he's for the street that's a fun fact Oh
no you're not gonna okay we're gonna
talk about it welcome back Sarah it's
been a minute it's been a minute I'm
back don't worry folks I'm back I know
I've seen people asking for me back on
the show you know I've been going
through some stuff you know helping
family out you know but but we're back
we're here and if you guys want to know
now
I am 41. I am
now I am not
I am not for the streets anymore okay
I'm now in a relationship
I'm in a relationship
come back to the streets my brother no
don't listen to him don't listen to him
and a fun fact is me is that I play golf
also guys Maggie also came all the way
from America she did a wife School
episode with me this week where you you
taught me how to throw it down in the
kitchen absolutely you did a great job
Pearl
welcome to the show thank you so much uh
so I'm Maggie The Substitute Teacher I
also have a YouTube channel I am 47
amicably divorced in a long-term
relationship and a fun fact is I make up
silly songs while I'm cooking nice are
we gonna see that on your channel
absolutely
I'm Camille Shantae I'm 21 next month
[Music]
and facts about me is that I'm bilingual
I speak English and Portuguese
that is cool
she has like the best accent ever can we
just say that's a fun fact too
relationship status
[Music]
go ahead
um I'm Lauren I am 33
and what was the next thing sorry your
name age relationship status and a fun
fact all right I am dating
um and a fun fact is I am a digital
Nomad business attorney oh
so you don't live anywhere
that's what that means right a digital
note Nomad it means you travel around
and you have different yeah you like go
from cool that's so fun yeah yeah go
ahead so I'm Chan Robson uh 25. soon to
be YouTuber trans Hawks uh seven year
happy relationship with Mrs because
saying girlfriend somewhat isn't grown
up
um and we actually run a clothing
business together fun fact
cool cool also guys um one announcement
I forgot to say at the start of the show
we have a Google form if you want to be
on our email list um we're gonna
announce meetups and also we may be
doing a red pill boxing match oh gosh
red pill blue pill conservatives versus
liberals you know
um
as much as the the right can say we dunk
on feminism we could literally fight
feminism in front of you so sign up for
that email list
um okay I think I think mid boxing match
the liberal was going to identify as a
woman
challenging I would say I want to fight
you but like we were like on the same
side so like who I don't know who to
fight who should I fight who's your
enemy who's your op Pastor okay
oh
right now let's go boo let's go what you
want
um do you know who Esther is I don't
care who Esther is because you know who
I am what is the question
um okay so um today's topic is are
modern women to blame for relationships
today
the dating market today
um so before we get too deep into that
I would like for you guys to define a
word that we hear so much about
I'd like for you guys to Define
accountability go here around in the
second row
accountability is being ultimately
responsible for all of your actions
whether it be positive or negative
accountability and
you know
owning it to a level where you're fixing
it like you can take accountability or
know that you've done wrong but like not
pointing to the to others and deflecting
but you're actually reflecting look in
the mirror and say what can I do to
change because that's the only person
you can you can change
I think accountabilities have an
introspection and self-reflection I
think it's about understanding who you
are and taking responsibly for all of
the decisions that you make in your life
yeah I would say accountability is
admitting what you did right and wrong
and then also accepting the consequences
of both
yeah I definitely agree I think taking
accountability is very important in life
and for self-development as well
I think um self-awareness but also the
ability to receive when other people
have something to say about you because
as self we can be jaded to what we don't
see about ourselves but we don't want to
hear what other people have to say about
us and that honestly is how we co-exist
with other people and we need to be
accountable for how others receive us so
that we can properly coexist
think accountability is being honest
with yourself and that once you admit
you're at fault you can grow from that I
think that's the most important thing
so who takes more accountability men or
women men men men men men men
why is you're shaking your head I think
women
we easily say sorry men don't say sorry
as much as women so definitely but men
say sorry and then continue to fix it
whereas women can't are so sorry and
then continue to make the same mistake I
think women rarely say something yeah
across the board I've I've never most
men one of their biggest gripes is that
women they will always move the goal
posts like if they're wrong then they
will kind of CounterPoint on how they
like how you caused it like even if they
cheat well you weren't emotionally
available so it's your fault no matter
what happens there's an excuse I rarely
hear a woman say I'm sorry honey I did
wrong I'm going to work on it you'll
never see me do this again please
forgive me well I think that's exactly
that's exactly accountability
[Laughter]
not in all situations but I do think
women held their hands up more than men
men Gaslight that's the thing there's
accountability and gaslighting so
so um I think that there's a difference
within our society I think that women
have the privilege in our modern day
society today to not be held accountable
I did a story not too long ago about a
year or so ago just popped into my head
where a young lady went down the NBA
All-Star weekend with not enough money
to get back home she then goes on
GoFundMe in order to get money in order
to go back home men cannot do that right
men do not have that type of reach and
or access to get free money sent to them
if they make a boo-boo how
so
Society in general just last Quick Point
Society in general has cushions put in
place for women more often than men
that's why most homeless people in
America are men it's like 90 to 10
percent 90 yeah I think when you say
that if you if you go on the modern day
tick tocks and whatever right you'll
find videos of women saying oh how to
apologize to your man just scoot up to
him naked with your ass out right and
that shows a lot of non-accountability
that shows when you say that okay women
are more accountable it's like no that's
how they apologize they think okay if we
have sex then everything's fine and so
yeah I think women don't hold themselves
accountable a lot I think women have a
hard time having that introspection I
think if you do they try to attack
people more so than actually accept that
I think in the time though while we live
in a time where women don't really need
to be accountable in a way that men are
always running around after them which I
think needs to stop and that's why that
they never have to really hold their
hands up and say look I'm sorry what
I've done wrong I'll try to fix this
because before it becomes an actual
issue the man's already there trying to
fix what they've done kind of listening
because I feel like in America this is
not the stance right I feel like the men
that I've come across in the dating
spectrum they are very passive they are
not quick to apologize they are very
gaslighting they don't accept
accountability into your point about a
man not being able to go to Vegas get
stuck and not make his way back you've
men these days because they're in the
streets doing whatever have accumulated
a bunch of women that care for them you
can paint her a stop story and she's
going to send you a hundred dollars
because she's caring and wants to
support you right so I think it's a
balance of each depending on the
circumstances in the person but I
definitely think women can be
accountable and from my circle and my
experiences are more accountable in this
generation of men who don't accept
accountability are not they Apologize by
actions right they just show up they
won't accept accountability for what
they did specifically a blanket apology
is not an apology if you are not owning
right that's the definition of lack of
accountability if you oh I'm just sorry
but what are we sorry for what are we
making improvements on right so I have a
question for you what was the last thing
that you apologized for what was the
last thing you took accountability for
um bad communication bad communication
yeah okay what you had something to say
I think maybe sometimes when I lose my
anger sometimes I'll blame it on other
things then the last thing I took
accountability for is when I got no do
you know what I overreacted with that
and I shouldn't have reacted in that way
so I apologize for that
can we clarify that accountability is
not the same as an apology right versus
accountability means that there is a
consequence after the action so either
that means okay you did that and because
of that this is the consequence and I
believe that is what men have to deal
with I think a lot of times women think
just by saying I'm sorry I'm accountable
that is not the same thing the amount of
times that I'm in dating relationships
with different women and listen they
just want to just complain about the
problem
I want to fix the problem correct I
don't want to continue to listen to you
just talk about what happened with you
and Marianne in the office right if you
come to me with an issue let's talk
about Solutions all right okay you can't
just waste my time at like that at the
end of the day let's talk about
Solutions but I find as though a lot of
women don't communicate in Solutions so
we talk about accountability the
consequences for that is to solution if
men in general are not accountable they
will not be successful if women in
general are not accountable they can
still be the wife to a CEO and they can
go on only fans using using that analogy
that same woman will complain to you
about you know what happened at work you
will say as a man okay cool what we
gonna do about it what are we doing
about are we going to fix it how are we
going to fix this she would say oh I
just wanted to vent and then the next
week or the next month she'll be
complaining to you about the same thing
so it's like okay but
how do you hold yourself accountable do
you want to face this woman or whoever
you have a problem with do you want to
get it out into the air do you want to
help the situation no they just want to
vent so yeah women talk a lot but they
don't
do a lot when somebody commits a crime
do we blame the criminal or do we blame
society
I think good men can become bad where
usually when you see men that have turnt
bad I think they always started out as
good men but being around certain people
in society can change them and twist
them for them so you guys think it's 50
50. I wouldn't say 50 50. yes
it's not 50 50. if I go down the street
and I steal something is it my fault or
Society no it's your fault it's your
fault it's nothing to do with Society
like if we want to blame the system then
that's the that's the that's the Crux of
no accountability like like if you want
to just blame what my childhood my
upbringing I didn't have this I didn't
have that the same person grew up in the
same circumstance as you and they made
other choices so we have to like that's
not accountability if it's if it's
always somebody else you know who who
caused it because you were raised a
certain way I can show you the example
of somebody raised in a worse
circumstances who made better choices
than you so is it really Society if if
we can if I can point to one person who
made a better choice sorry if I make if
I could poison one person who made a
better choice then
like like you haven't your excuses gone
but there's a moral and there's a moral
story in that so for instance if you
look at people like Robin Hood right
Robin Hood was born into a poor Society
right and what he chose to do was to rub
from the rich and give to the poor right
so was he was he wrong so I have a
question so if a guy cheats can he blame
society no no absolutely not no he has
no no discipline with his tool
why can't why can't he just blame hookup
Culture by that logic no just if you
want to hook up yeah be single leave
just leave I don't understand that yeah
but it will talk just leave but I think
it also depends on your on your end goal
so like I said with Robin Hood with the
Robin Hood analogy he robbed from the
rich gave to the poor to try and change
society so so women were like they they
this woman
and these poor women out here aren't
getting enough D so he's giving charity
because that's essentially what your
example is no I'm just talking about
morally depends on that's why I said
it's depends I never said this 50 50 I
said it could also be the society could
also be the individual I'm just saying I
would say it would depend on what you
want from say so people like if you're
trying to change society for instance
look at Andrew Tate he's trying to
change society right but he's deemed as
wrong that's why he's been jailed just
people don't know right because people
don't like lactate
well if we're honest but he's done
things right I will say there are moves
he's made that people are on on his side
will say listen you you self-snitched
like you you should have kept it quiet
there's moves that he needs to yeah
we're talking about that we're talking
about whether he's is that society's
fault if you self snitch is he wrong
and for what he's trying to do with him
if you self snitch you have to learn how
to move we're in the world we're in and
I'm not saying he's right or wrong what
I'm saying is that's what we're talking
about but I'm saying is but he has to
also does Andrew Tate have to take
accountability if he's self-centered but
if you if you you can you can sing about
something in a song or talk about
something on social media without it
technically being self-snitching they
have to bring evidence that you did
those exactly they have no evidence
against him so I agree with you they
have no evidence so they need to let
that go their feelings are hurt so
that's why I said Society because
Society could deem somebody wrong
because they're the ones in the room so
if I have power the original question
was about the CH about the stealer so if
I go down and steal is it my fault or
Society but let's just think if you're
if you're raised in poverty you have no
money you're in a circumstance where you
have no food and you're raising us and
you're living let's say you're a kid and
you have no money you have no food
you're dependent on parents who are on
drugs and and your your baby sister
needs to eat your mother's on crack like
there are nuances in this where you you
have to blame a portion of society that
this child has failed because we've let
them slip through the system
but how would that child eat how do they
eat tell me the solutions if their
parents are parents will crack their
baby sister their little brothers and
sisters are hungry they can't get a job
they're 13. I personally know of people
like this kids in homeless shelters this
is their situation Maggie understood
that wrong is still wrong there may be
reasons why this kid is stealing but we
still have to be able to say wrong is
wrong and as a parent I mean you hear it
even in parenting advice you know they
tell you oh the child is not bad they
just made bad decisions where I grew up
in an era where if you were a fool they
called you a fool yeah and I think we
need to bring some of that back because
it breeds this thing well it's not my
fault sometimes it just has to sit on
you and you just have to realize I did
that and it was wrong so is that a moral
question then like when you say wrong is
wrong because who decides what is wrong
and what is right but then the question
is well if you are let's say you're a
teenager or young your mother's on crack
there's a recent store in the U.S where
a mother left her two children her 14
year old ran away her 12 year old and
she has a three-year-old all three
different baby daddies she left him
alone in Texas is in Houston for two
months through Thanksgiving she told
them if you tell anybody that I'm
leaving that they're going to take your
little three-year-old brother away and
you'll never see him again and
threatened her so she was scared to tell
anybody what was going on her mother was
missing for two months or she was
running the streets in another state she
was left in the carrot she never
enrolled these children into school
the oldest one so she used to have to
lie to her father who was working in
another state because of course she got
custody of all the kids okay so then she
because she was threatened because the
mother said I'll never love you or see
you you'll never see your siblings again
this child had to lie to her father and
say can you please get groceries mom is
working he would call the mother say
yeah I'm working can you please send
groceries or food I'm struggling but she
couldn't tell the truth because she was
scared if that instance if she didn't
have food didn't have the father who
would who would send the groceries or
food to the house and she had to go
steal are we going to say little 12 year
old you are now accountable because your
mother's for the streets and abandon you
in your in your little sibling and now
you need consequences I think there's
you can have empathy for a situation but
but the whole idea is wrong is wrong
exactly your mom
and you could say this is why I did that
wrong thing and like this is my reason
for it but wrong is still wrong
it doesn't become right just because
something happened exactly it doesn't
matter well that's tough for me that one
that's a tough I think it's odd so
suppose for instance if I got up and
slapped you in your face right now am I
wrong yes sir yeah if you snap me back
are you wrong yes no no but remember you
made the decision to slap me no because
once in self-defense all right
once and then he just stands there and
is
just needed he just slapped you it's
still self-defense
what if he slaps you and it goes sits
back down
stand up and do it again but but what if
he doesn't what if like he's held back
are you are you should you be able how
would he be helpful how do we get here
why is it that when a man cheat He
Cheats he's a cheater but when a woman
cheats she's not satisfied in the
relationship
because can we women cheat emotionally
and men cheat because there's a hole in
the wall
right that's why men cheat sounds like
an excuse me no no I'm just saying
listen it's a corn category right it's
called glory holes you see men putting
their things in they don't care who's on
the other side they're just trying to
get their rocks off right men can do
that men don't care right women actually
for a woman to cheat on a man she has to
be somewhat emotionally involved
questions
men can do it without having any
emotions yeah yeah no but the question
was different though yeah that's not
what I asked no but you said why no I
said why why does society label the man
a cheater but a woman's not satisfied in
the relationship so why is there an
excuse for for the woman but there's not
an excuse me because it's an account no
it's an accountability issue I agree
it's accountability issue for sure
listen at the end of the day um one of
the things that we open up with is that
there's
um systems put in place for whatever
reason to continue to Pander to the
modern woman and I think it's all just
kind of just based off of money I think
that if you want to sell ad placements
to the
the component of the population that
makes 80 percent of the household
purchasing decisions you're going to do
so in a way to try to make them feel
good and nice inside and avoid all
accountability at the end of the day
accountability doesn't feel good having
to fix problems doesn't feel good it's
time intensive and it brings you a dose
of reality of the things that you have
to do to over encumber that right women
don't want to do all that [__] they just
want to just want to feel good about
themselves and let it be the man's issue
or the man's problem like again they're
not focus on Solutions generally but
that's the thing as well say as a man
you need to take accountability for
something and say you seem upset or
distraught about it there is nothing
more disgusting than a dude who doesn't
take accountability exactly it's nasty
but get away from me I don't even want
guy friends who don't take
accountability get away from me but me
personally as a man who do you go to to
talk to about it because personally I
don't have anyone I don't know about the
other men but I know you don't have
mentors
other people I think of mentors but not
people that I would go to emotionally to
talk about my problems as as a man you
sit there and deal with them yourself
but I know all women mates and my Mrs
mates and so on where if they're in
trouble something went wrong whatever
and there's oh my God only talked to
someone about this 10 15. oh if I was
alive he's all right yeah why can't you
go to your father
I don't know we have this conversation
no we have a we have a great
relationship he's um he's role model in
some ways but he has his own problems
that I don't wanna you don't want to go
and bother someone else with your
problems no my number one is my pops if
things are right like my pops
um you know he's my example of what to
be a man in modern day society today is
especially you know being a black man in
America he is my example and I make sure
that big decisions that are within my
life of things that I may not know the
answers to and I consider myself a
genuinely sometimes most of the times a
wise guy you know but for things that
you know I just can't quite figure out
and make sure that I go to him now I
know at the same time there's a lot of
young men out there that don't have that
Father Figure and actually I think
that's a large degree in a component
that's why channels like mine have blown
up is because there's a lot of men young
men out there that might have been
raised in a single parent household that
have questions regarding things that are
happening to themselves within their
lives that they don't quite have the
answer to so I'm actually surprised to
hear that your father is as active what
he is but you don't go to him it might
be different between England and America
but from over where I'm from in
Southampton pretty much every guy that I
know would say the same as me so maybe
it's uh I don't know a different
are you saying that culturally men are
taught not to say anything then
growing up in schools yet I think it was
always man up get on and do this sort
this out and I think that's the struggle
men go through and the men can actually
talk what it is that's what it is what
you guys don't understand is that women
relate emotionally like we can empathize
and so when a woman goes through
something or she cheats we we feel this
we can we try to like bring empathy to
what she what's going on with her men
are you know are more logical in their
thinking and deductive reasoning this
goes into biology and and how men's
Brains are wired so logically women will
always try to you know there's
confirmation bias as well because there
are other women so like we we wouldn't
give an excuse to a woman who sleeps
with our husband or our man and like we
got a problem with that but if it's our
girlfriend someone we like or someone in
The Sisterhood there's this kind of like
this camaraderie men do it as well men
feel a camaraderie for each other so but
I will say overall men are much more
you know like they're gonna men are made
to to discipline men are made they're
not going to get into the emotions of
like I don't like my father I don't care
what you felt what did you do like like
quit the quit the crying quit the tears
I get it you feel this way but you have
real world consequences and I think most
women are either treated like princesses
by their fathers or they don't have
accountability growing up they don't
know what it looks like and this is why
they're offended by it and if something
happens to another woman we want to be
understanding because we automatically
empathy puts us in their shoes like we
could see how they feel because we may
have felt a certain way even if we've
never done that action but it doesn't
excuse it away they still need to be
held accountable but that's why so many
women Buck against conversations like
this because it's like how dare you say
something is all these men and men and
women cheat at almost the same rate but
yet it's always meant women but actually
Maggie I wonder what were you shaking
your head at uh yeah I mean you you said
a few things there Melanie some I agree
with I think we ended up where we agreed
but I think ultimately men have the
burden of Duty and honor put on them
that women don't and so to answer your
question as to why a man would be
labeled a cheater is because you're
supposed to do right where a woman is
coddled and kind of given well the there
there which I don't agree with we can
still empathize and still call it wrong
for example back to the other point if
I'm speeding through a traffic light
because my son is in an accident I'm
trying to get to the hospital I go
through a red light it's still wrong I
may explain the reason why but if I have
to pay a ticket for it I pay a ticket
for it where we are it's like oh I
understand go ahead and you know go
scot-free so that's what I wanted to say
what are what do you think of this
conversation I I think um
one of the things that you said is kind
of the the empathy of
um women
um and why you guys you know kind of
communicate like that and I often think
like you know I you know if I think I
like like the entrance of like a
therapist is I would say a lot more
beneficial to most modern women than
they are to Modern Men depending upon
the type of therapist that you go to I
think men should go to male therapists
but the thing is is like the downfall of
a lot of modern women today outside of
the Sims the white Knights is other
modern women that are unwilling to hold
them accountable and they'll get into
these Echo chamber circles and just
Kumbaya around the totally incorrect
thing and that's why right like I I
suggest and you know Kevin used to do it
as well too suggest therapy to a lot of
modern women because they can get a
third party arbitrator to understand the
situation and be like do you know one of
those things to be the Bearer in the bad
news however you know what's wrong you
know one of the reasons why they do that
M2
competition
women see each other as competition
women never give each others the keys to
the game okay so when older women get
older right they never give younger
women the game because the older women
are actually vying for the same types of
men that the younger women are vying for
right and so you never ever tell your
opponent the key to the game you can
consult them oh my baby you're so bad is
that what you've done oh my God amazing
but the same types of men that the older
women want the same types of men that
the younger women want so the older
women are never going to give you the
game because they see you as competition
yeah I want to talk about that earlier
Pearl and I were talking about that
earlier I want to come back to you baby
because you aren't you aren't talking
much do you feel do you have older women
in your life that hold you accountable
um well I actually hold myself
accountable no no no no no one can hold
you you can't hold yourself accountable
because we're our own like if you don't
have outside voice we just see ourselves
how we see ourselves accountability
comes from someone saying listen
accountability hurts we don't hurt
ourselves we don't tell ourselves the
things that we need to hear you're
dating a guy you like him and an older
woman say
I see this is going on I see like this
guy is not you know that you can trust
and know that she's not competing with
you do you have an older woman in your
life yeah definitely you know um some of
my mom's friends when I was a bit more
open with my relationship they would
always like throw things at me like oh
if he does this oh he's probably
cheating things like that and it's just
I could tell you know they were in
competition and they just didn't want me
to be happy so definitely really well
until it's like so they actually tried
to put your relationship and your man
down did you feel like they were trying
to they they their negativity or their
negative experiences they were trying to
put on you and him extremely negative
they would just it would just always be
something and then now I'm very very
private with my relationship and just
private with my life but like they've
never met him so it's like how how do
you have so much to say so because
do you have anybody a woman an older
woman who says I love you the only thing
I want is the best for you they're not
in competition they're not trying to put
negativity they want to hear what you
have to say they want to meet him love
on him and actually get the real thing
do you have any woman in your life like
that that's older okay so this is a
failure
Maggie what we talked about just on her
podcast we did yesterday older women we
have failed younger women like her I'm
41. you just you're about to turn 21.
yeah like we're a 20 year difference
well you know like mothers as well I
sometimes feel like mothers in
competition with their daughters
absolutely yeah we just talked about do
you feel as though and I don't want to
put your mother on the spot or anything
you can talk in general but do you find
like what your friends or your
experience that the moms they put like a
competition they don't want you to win
because they failed yeah yeah and and
they and they will talk you into failure
right don't don't worry about it they
will console you though right but but
they'll talk you into failure and then
once you fail they'll be like oh it's
okay baby and like I said it's for it's
a if in my personal point of views for
competition about men because the same
man that is going for the 21 year old
that was the 21 year old he will sleep
with you too Melanie yeah
in a misery loves company yeah it's like
when you when you fail a test what
what's the best feeling in the world
when you turn to someone
in a class that failed
in your circle that failed I actually
noticed it on Tick Tock like it would
there was a group of like moms and they
did like the mom content and then one
gets divorced then the other gets
divorced and the other gets to it's like
the whole damn friend group and it's
just like misery really loves company
they don't want to be alone in their bad
decisions single women keep single women
single right right if the older women
have not kept their own relationship
together then it's really hard to wish
that uh blessing on someone else so I
think you have to be very selective and
find someone that is in a relationship
that you actually admire and they're
secure in that relationship I think if
you're trying to get advice from older
single women that's where it can really
go live but sometimes married women as
well because how many married women do
we know wish they could be back in the
streets right that's miserable in their
marriage I know so many who are just
like they see the glamor of being flown
to Dubai and they don't know they're
getting flown they single again flown to
Dubai because they're laying down with a
camera you're getting flown and blown no
no no they've flown and blown that is
what is going on they're actually
selling but we don't because what
happens is younger guys that you may be
what's the oldest guy you've dated well
this is my little second boyfriend and
he's 23. okay yeah so he's not that much
older yeah but that same 23 year old
will try to
will sleep with and go after someone my
age is he serious this happens every day
but I say to myself like so what happens
is these older women will feel like okay
well that little 20 something year old
she can't do nothing for you boo let's
come over here and I'm gonna do this I'm
gonna put it on you she's not grown
she's immature this is how these older
women are thinking these cougars and so
they see you as competition instead of
loving on you and wanting you to win or
they'll use shaming language like
calling the dude a pedo when it's just
like no he just likes younger women yeah
it's and but when they were younger
creepy or he's crazy I don't know a
single older woman who when she was
younger did not date an older guy but
once they get older it's like oh well I
was naive then I didn't know and all
this other stuff so like yeah I dated an
older guy but it's it really was abusive
and I'm just thinking to myself will you
really abused dating an older guys
Financial abuse credit card right they
feel that way and and that's why I
wanted to talk to her because I said as
a younger woman like you know this is
our whole conversation Maggie we were
talking about this yesterday about older
women are competing for the same men
they don't realize that the older women
think because these men will your
boyfriend I'm not saying he is but your
boyfriend will sleep with a woman who's
older and so they think they're in
competition with you and they have to
prove this but they should have been out
the game a long time ago you can see in
The Tick Tock videos right when you see
like mother and daughters right and the
mother looks quite young
that's your competition right there and
it's like the mother's trying to keep up
with her yes but on the flip side men
like MTR men like myself right we may be
older we're trying to give younger men
the game we're trying to say look young
guys this is what you do this is what
you don't do right this older guys what
I've realized older guys don't mind
giving younger guys a game they won't
they don't mind telling them where they
went wrong okay I don't mind telling a
young the guy where I went wrong do you
know what I mean and generally generally
dudes if you're in competition of
another with another dude usually it's
more brute strength fruit uh you know in
competition physically uh downright to
fighting status financials uh generally
women compete utilizing manipulation
innuendo uh reputation destruction we're
not giving you the keys to whatever it
is that you're trying to do right
because women don't generally fight just
based off of right like physical power s
but there's other things that they do
Wonder right women aren't holding each
other accountable but it also sounds
like we aren't holding men accountable
right that they are able to go and do
these things with multiple women and
attract to that right so why are we so
why is that our standard I have a
question so um are you aware that one
one in three men are either virgins or
haven't had sex in the past year yes
given the weight that women date and
things like that yep what percent of men
do you think are sexually active in
sleeping with multiple women
hmm
I think it's like 30 or 40 or something
like 10. it's a weightless it's five to
ten percent yeah so it's like you're
gonna put five to ten percent of men's
decisions on all of all
on all of men when really it's like 80
of women that are sleeping with them
amen that's it so I'm thinking women
need to take the accountability right so
so it's who's it more on women for sure
that's what I was posing that women
aren't holding women accountable but the
men the five to ten percent of men that
are out doing that they're doing it with
all of the 87 and we aren't holding them
accountable but the women should they
because the women are throwing
themselves right like Drake like what
these girls are these girls are waiting
well back to the question wrong is wrong
right no no no no no no no
you can't hold Men wrong for developing
themselves to be as best as what they
positively and ultimately can be and
then they get all of this coochie thrown
at them okay the concept
of groupie is a strictly female term
it's not it on the flip side right so
like I I think like listen at the end of
the day there's a whole media engine put
in the place to hold men accountable I
don't want no scrubs scrub is a guy
from me
[Music]
come on come on and on top of that on
the flip side they got the women singing
about being Miss Independent I don't
cook I don't clean all of these things
that don't hold them accountable for
being a good marriageable wife
women though are actually wives or want
to be wives but they're telling us like
I don't cook I don't clean them for the
street city girls the city girls are
talking about we're independent but then
you're so desperate for a man the
benefits of being modern and not the
consequences of being modern they want
the benefits of being modern and the
benefits of being conservative or
traditional at the same damn time while
a whole media engine is have been
holding men accountable since TV was TV
since love connection was on the goddamn
TV screen and all up until today the
music the TV not YouTube because we hold
them accountable over here and every
other forms of media the movies the
Disney they've been holding guys
accountable since the beginning of time
the talk shows shout out to Steve Harvey
shout out to the Derrick Jacksons y'all
been holding guys accountable now we
have platforms today where men can hold
women accountable and y'all get mad at
us
who do you think's in control of sex men
or women oh women so then wouldn't you
say it's women's fault for giving out
sex for free so let's not get this
confused I am a hundred percent that
women are not being held accountable at
all right but it we there's a balancing
factor and why can that coexist yes we
aren't holding each other accountable or
things like that but there's still a
standard of a men allowing that that we
aren't hold accountable but it's not the
only thing that I'm saying but that's
the only thing what we've already proven
is that it's not the majority of men it
is a five to ten percent that women are
choosing to give their bodies to and lay
down with do you know there are between
18 and 30 there are I I think the
numbers three times the number of men
who are virgins then there are girl than
women who are virgins women can run
through body count and run through I
mean I did a a video where I talked
about how I read women's body counts
like women
anonymously business women these are not
women they're strippers and for of the
street they actually gave their body
count there was a 29 year old woman that
had 150 plus and she said I wish it was
higher oh my God and even women who had
low body count low numbers of men they
said it should be higher they actually
feel embarrassed like I should be living
little and and I used to feel there was
there's no shame about it if you ask the
same men unless they are certain looks
they have a certain amount of looks or
money and Status they can't get the
average woman if if all of us women went
outside right now and was just like
listen
come back to the crib let's go to the
car let's go to the alley I'm gonna bust
it down for you I'm gonna give it to you
we can rack up the whole city we can
rack up all of London
but a man if they can go outside even if
they look good even after status they
still have a level of work they they may
be on a good night could maybe get two
if they are just really really really
have sex with who they want men have sex
and only one of them changes to the
outcome of their relationships in the
future I mean I'm not I'm not gonna say
that it has no impact but which one has
significantly more if a man sleeps with
100 100 women can he settle down I would
argue still yeah but what if a woman
sleeps with a hundred men she men she
can't women men care about quantity
women care about quality of the women so
if I see I'm like that's your
ex-girlfriend that's who you slap with
uh like if she's like a bus down or I
know she's a known hoe or the dude just
slept with processes we would be upset
as women a man will care about the
number of men that she has slept with we
care about about the quality because
we're almost like that's why that's why
if a girl if a man has a other women
around him who look good other women
around him that look good or his
girlfriend looks good he's like
pre-qualified we're just like oh he's
got a baddie it in US it incites like
he's pre-qualified whereas we care about
if we see a good looking guy with like a
girl that looks terrible like he's
probably broke he's probably this I
won't want him a man doesn't care about
that all he gives was quantity what were
you gonna say but to the point right
it's 80 of women who are out here doing
these things it's five to ten percent of
men who are sleeping with them but they
are running through the 80 percent of
women and now they are disqualifying
them from being good good wives so it
first needs that's the choice
so women are opening their legs you just
said that women control sex how would
the 80 of men just running through these
women
ability needs to start with women and
locking that down and not doing that
right so then the five to ten percent of
men who are running have no place to go
right that is
the accountability because because all
the women are sleeping with that five to
ten percent so we need to women need the
accountability the five to ten percent
like like so we're sharing like no I'm
sorry the majority of men do not make
accounts that's not women if 80 of women
are choosing these five to ten percent
ma'am you have not you sweetheart I'm
just talking in general I know when I
say ma'am I'm just talking so I'm just
saying like how are we going to blame
men when it's five to ten percent that's
getting 80 percent of the women out here
it's us women if five percent five to
ten percent of women were choosing to
sleep with those five to ten percent men
let them go off and do their thing but
we have women in Mass the majority of
women that are giving themselves to
these low quality tyrones pookies and
ray rays that don't really that don't
care when those good men that are right
around you but you don't want him
because he's corny and only one
influences the outcome of your
relationship like the the man sleeping
with multiple women it's not going to
influence the outcome of his
relationship but it sure as hell is
going to influence the outcome of hers
for her future husband we know so that
makes it okay though but we live in a
time where we can watch all these Tick
Tock videos with these Street interviews
and the guys are asking girls about what
have you done what's what's what have
you got to confess and these girls are
saying they've been ran through they've
had five guys in one night and we've now
got to the point yeah we've got to the
point are you dude I believe that sex
outside of marriage is wrong
so yes but yeah but do you still partake
yes right so in modern culture it's it's
relevant right then you're blaming
culture I'm not blaming culture that's
just what that's a reality
right but that's your as an individual
you have individual accountability I
don't care what culture is doing I make
a choice with my box culture is not
going to give me STD culture is not
going to give make me I'm culture's not
going to take care of when I have a um
you know I'm an unwed mother culture is
not going to take care of those things I
am responsible for my body my my who I
give my body to her soul ties to if you
choose to spread your legs open in these
streets Society did not make you do that
you made the choice to lay down with all
of those men and you can and putting it
on it many exact accountability you
chose to bust it open for that F boy or
or that Pookie that is your choice
however I'll say this go off when your
Society tells you that something is okay
so what seen within the next we've been
the past 10 years is a spike in people
that are calling themselves non-binary
and trans right we've seen a spike in it
why because the society has said it's
okay to be that way that's their choice
right it is that it is their choice but
I'm saying we have to understand that
when society says something is okay it
has an impact on individuals like this
is the reality because there's a reason
why you don't allow your children to
watch certain things on TV right now
every single day it has to be but hang
on there's a reason why you don't allow
your children to watch certain things on
TV there's a reason why you don't allow
your children to go around certain
people why because as much as you could
teach your child and say don't do this
that's wrong right your child can still
be influenced right by a certain people
your choice even as a child it's your
choice who you surround yourself with
like I remember being like a kid and
thinking these girls are mad I think
these girls were crazy and it's like
even even as a child you have some
accountability for the the friends you
choose to surround yourself with but
what where does accountability come from
it comes from the influences it comes
from our society and all I'm saying is
we can't
discredites
I don't agree accountability comes from
yourself and the ability to take away
from everyone
every woman that has laid down with the
five to ten percent man there is another
woman who was raised in some of the
circumstances or worse that made a
different decision so that's where your
accountability is because you can have
all the excuses Society everybody all of
this but there is another person out
there that made a different and a better
choice just because you were born in
that then you have to say why did they
make a better choice and I chose to do
this so if one person in the world made
a better choice than you then you have
to say Society didn't influence them
Society didn't do this why am why am I
so weak why am I so unaccountable that I
want to blame everyone else if one
person has made a better choice than you
then you need to rise to the cream of
the crop but so many of us are at the
bottom we want to be like everybody else
we want to be regular we want to be at
we want to be below average and we don't
strive for excellence in anything that
we do creates Society I think we're
missing something the one percent of men
do who know I'm saying like who passes
on culture in a family exactly and then
yeah one thing that that's missing it is
talking about the individual and we're
talking about Society we have completely
neglected the home and the family
because I would argue that if an older
woman had told this younger lady or any
younger lady that this is how boys see
you if you do that you would act
differently if someone had told you that
I think men do a much better job of
checking each other because men see
themselves in younger men
women see themselves as younger women so
a man bars she's good you better teach
ERS
a man looks at his life in phases he
knew he was a boy he knew he was a young
man he knew he was you know a bachelor
and then he's like I'm ready to set it
down a woman doesn't do that a woman
still thinks even though I'm 40 or 50 or
whatever I can still twerk like a little
girl I can still wear revealing clothing
I think there's some Sierra
men build societies women pass on the
culture typically yes they do and so by
that by that logic if the culture's bad
whose fault is it
the women and the who's breaking up
homes no matter what the whole word
right there so and and if if we're if
we're growing up in a family that
doesn't in a society that doesn't value
family whose fault is it no I think
that's women I agree they're breaking up
the home we actually done something on
that and I actually said uh if the
woman's not right because she's the
first teacher of children right so if
the woman's not right the society is not
going to be right because if you're the
first teacher of the children as women
you spend most of the time with the
children so if you are the one that is
constantly and consistently around the
children then the child's not going to
be right and the Childs are the ones
that go out into society
I think I actually heard you said well
before that's the thing in single mother
homes that's when kids do bad you always
deemed a father figure in the home to be
able to coach and teach the child how to
be disciplined and accountable in life
there are some though in single months
we have these outliers like LeBron James
single mother
um you know family and even his wife
Savannah James that's how I brought her
her up if you saw her a picture of
Sierra and you put a picture of of
Savannah James at the Oscars
Savannah James Every Woman across the
board like people are talking about
that's my wedding dress like she's
inspired me she is she is gold she is it
she was a single mother very young she
was raised by a single mother LeBron
James so even even if you raise a single
mother poverty all your circumstances
look at people who made different
choices if they made other choices you
have no excuse if somebody else came out
of your sisters and let's be honest
right now ladies and gentlemen
everything we're talking about right now
is very lightweight and weak if we look
at history and what people have gone
through in real struggle and what we
call you know hardship and it's not my
my choice look I mean you look at the
society as a whole throughout you know
all of Europe Africa and everywhere we
are living in a time of of absolute
privilege and so when we when we in the
accountability that they had to take
that it is just even this conversation
is is is spoiled and it is is privileged
and it is very we don't know hard work
we don't know what it's like to really
struggle so we can even have the luxury
of having these conversations like this
and and and and it's it's it was life
and death for a woman to lose her
virginity to the streets okay it was
life and death it means you would be a
destitute you were actually sent to the
brothels if you aged out you know
because you did not marry at a certain
age you were sent to work in the in the
Brothel House changed right and so it
now it's only fans and so and and
Instagram so what we're seeing is even
these conversations we really as a
society now don't know accountability
and I mean if we really want to go there
but overall I would say absolutely the
onus is on the women to pass down the
culture teach the young women our young
women are out of pocket struggling
because the older women are for the
streets many of them you have women who
are in their 40s still being IG models
getting bust down down and flew out flew
flewed out is what they call it and just
doing the most and looking like
strippers what we call even cute outfits
today sexy this is what you know I I
don't know what I'm gonna say the word
but like women of uh uh ladies of the
night would wear in old times and
there's no accountability you're 45
years old man and you're dressing like
your daughter doing Tick Tock and trying
to show how thick you are because you
want that same 30 year old man because
if your daughter can get you can get the
same man he'll be in let's say he's 33
you're 40 your daughter's 20. he's 30.
you're trying to get that man because
you're so lost and so consumed into
yourself you have nothing to teach you
but old box but I think that's the
reason why men are supposed to be the
ones leading Society exactly right and I
think that's the reason why
um because we like I said discussed
earlier on women are not going to give
younger women the keys to the game it's
just not going to do it it's competition
they're not going to do it sitting
around asking and expecting them to do
it you'll be waiting a long time for
them to do that right so it's for
mentally Society so when you talk about
Society about Society has been
fragmented and it's been broken so now
men can be women and women can be men
and the whole thing's topsy-turvy and
upside down and so the reason for
society being this way is because men
aren't allowed to lead men like TMR men
like myself we get called misogynistic
do you know what I mean when we try to
lead we get called all types of Earth
doesn't say so if if you're Dusty then
say so if you're if you're gay then say
so we get shamed for trying to be
leaders do you get what I'm saying so
the society going back to who leads
Society
um I would say there's a part of like I
said those one percent of men
whoever they are those one percent the
same people that put Andrew Tate in jail
those men are the ones that are trying
to
um cultivate society and show people
that if you step out of line like an
entry Tate then they'll try and put you
back in check modern women hate
accountability so much that they cheered
when Kevin Samuels passed away
accountability by and large but here's
the thing is that
because they are the product of the
society they are raised in and a lot of
them are just Hive Minds
that I can't really be mad at them at
the end of the day because if you've
been lied to consistently throughout
your life or fed the propaganda
that sells a product to you
and you believe that because it benefits
you they cannot really be mad at you
that you fed into the propaganda well
there's examples all throughout history
where propaganda has led to some of the
uh the most major calamities throughout
our history and our civilization because
people just believed in something
unwittingly and unknowingly without
questioning it but do you guys think
that the phrase is actually go ahead and
Mark oh no I was just gonna say and to
your point MTR I think what Kevin
Samuels did was hold up a mirror and we
had a decision to make yes we had been
lied to yes some of us had those modern
Tendencies but it was basically a Line
in the Sand and then you can say okay am
I going to stick my head back in the
sand la la and say I don't want to hear
that anymore and you should go away bad
man or am I going to say you know what
am I really fit feminine and friendly
right and those same women who cheered
his death you still lonely you still
need to buy a dog and die alone and you
still and you still aren't succeeding
but you've listened I I Kevin was a
personal friend of mine he was a
personal friend of him of MTR here and
like we knew he loved he was trying to
help he was the stern father you never
had see I had a father my father sounds
like Kevin to this day and holds me
accountable but see if you've never had
somebody tell you the truth like ma'am
what like your mindset your attitude
what's your the way you're moving like
like I'm sorry like and and actually
there's so much pride and ego in women
today because we've been pandered to and
told everybody's a queen everybody's a
princess you know everybody is you know
just because you're born with uh female
anatomy then that means that you should
be treated a certain way but every day
we see in the news there are women who
are not fit to even walk the earth that
what they've done to their children what
they've done to other people there's
just a scandal that came out I won't say
the word but this woman falsely accused
several young men of doing something to
her these young men try to delete
themselves because it was absolutely lie
now evidence came out recently where she
went to the store bought a hammer beat
herself oh my goodness oh my gosh
if it wasn't for other men coming around
and supporting these young men and they
were these these older men were canceled
for because they were trying to
um support men who did essay and just
because she was a woman she was believed
and I'm not saying that doesn't happen
happen to my mother that's how I have an
older my older sister came from that
when she was 14. so of course I actually
come from a family that's happened but I
still know several stories of women who
have falsely accused ruined these young
men's lives and guess what you know what
society says after that
that young woman she this is one woman
who was finally held accountable because
of her lies and destroying their life
but do you know what happened those
young men most of them who have been
falsely accused they lose their
scholarship they use their jobs they
lose everything and then there's nothing
to say if it goes away and it wasn't
true you never hear accountability you
never hear any woman go to jail
there needs to be a law for it who do
you think pushes when you you mentioned
that women are told that they're Queens
they're princesses they're special who
do you think pushes that more men or
women I think women because women
influence like my father never called me
a princess like I never understood this
Prince I think my father called me
meatball because I was a little fat
little baby and my entire life he used
to say maybe you're getting a little
thick let's go to the gym so if we blame
society so in a way if we blame society
if women are the ones that pass on
culture
and women are the ones that are pushing
these lives more than men in a way when
we say Society we're really talking
about women
yeah because we we won because women
this is this is why Society is the way
it is because women by women have the
purchasing power in in the world we buy
everything be so corporations media have
learned Pander to women their needs
their feelings because men aren't buying
things more men are more price conscious
not all but most men are not just
spending frivolously and so women we
will just spend on our feelings we we we
spend it's by 90 I think the purchasing
power so media and culture has has set
up things so that women feel good
because they are the ones that are going
to make them rich I mean that goes into
a lot of layers and a lot of levels but
that's the reason why our society is the
way it is and why women are not held
accountable because it's not profitable
I just want to just bring it back to the
quick point is that like I don't know
like if I ever get elected into any
house or Congress or anything like that
I there's got to be way to make these
false allegations illegal like like
there have like there has to be
something listen
most men have a friend that has had a
friend if not them that's been falsely
accused most men know of a man who they
have a child with the lovely young lady
the child the the child's mother can
utilize some false accusation to remove
that child from that man's life [__] I
got a story on my channel me being
falsely accused of some [__] we all all
of us we all but see we want to talk
about that um we want to talk about uh
holding them accountable all of a sudden
we want to talk about that can we talk
about the DNA testing center I've had it
I had two guys call in they work a DNA
testing centers one guy had to quit one
guy still works there he told me 40 of
the children are not the man's child 40
40 he said 40 somebody it's usually DNA
testing
it's two scenarios it's where the woman
the person's getting a DNA test because
the woman claims that is their child
turns out it's not the other one is
where the parent is on the death bed and
makes a confession or they need a health
they need a liver transplant blood
transfusion and the blood type there's
no way that that can actually be the
father so then they find out that
because of medical reasons you mean
that's not my father then the father
finds out from that way he said it took
such a toll on him that he could no
longer do it because he would be sitting
on the phone counseling the men and the
grown children
who these women falsely Clues we see it
on more we see it on paternity court but
yet we say many to be held accountable
why are these women needing all these
why does Mori exist with you or not the
father the court exists
do you know what would happen if DNA
testing was mandatory if they tested all
women
Calamity my sister told me this should
be standard my sister told me the last
that's why they won't do it he said it
should be a standard thing at the
hospital that's why they won't do it to
me it just makes sense give an epidural
DNA test I'm doing it I'm doing a
documentary on the court system here in
the UK and I um I was interviewing this
guy he he works for it's called fathers
for justice and they help men get
custody of their kids and one thing I
found out is in the UK um you are
actually given a free free Council which
is a lawyer basically if you accuse your
husband of abuse and what the women can
do is they can accuse the guy of abuse
and
um file a restraining order against him
even if he did nothing and if he breaks
that he actually goes to jail and it can
take one to two years to even get the
kid back so he could have a newborn and
not see the kid for two years over a
false allegation and then so he told me
this story of this guy who the mom
accused him of touching the kids
and it destroyed his social life it
destroyed everything he got he got let
go from his job and the man he called
the guy and said I'm going to kill
myself and hung up and he said thank you
for helping me but I can't do this I'm
gonna kill myself and he shot himself in
the head but that's what happened in a
DNA Center that's what a guy quit and so
are are the women held accountable for
causing the men to do that over a false
allegation well no because even if that
turns out that's false of the man that
still sticks with him forever forever
you're guilty regardless you're guilty
until proven innocent for me same thing
as the essence it's not guilty it's not
innocent until proven guilty it's guilty
until proven innocent you put it out
which is that what Amber Heard and
Johnny Depp that's right look what just
happened with that ESPN don't get me
started
what's his name I don't really watch
sports like that I forget his name but I
know you're talking about he just and
because of a false allegation because of
that he was not allowed to report at the
at the Super Bowl off of off of that now
he's suing him for like 10 minutes
millions of dollars or something like
that it's absolutely Preposterous Amber
Heard should awoke all women you know
about the Amber Heard case yeah okay so
Amber Heard the me too all of that to
this day she is still lying through her
teeth and we had to there are sa victims
S.A counselors that actually support
um to support Johnny Depp because we
could see it for ourselves there are
women you may not be that way right so a
lot of women we internalize it and we'll
say well my friends and the people I
know but there are so many women who are
like Amber hurt who to Punisher is a
complete the lion and
um she took a [__] on his back no no no
nasty young woman
but not only that but what she did she
she um violated him the things in her
lives are ratchet up and guess what
happened in society just because she
made the accusation
he his life was destroyed it took him
six years in the public trial in order
to get it out there if that trial was
not published if that trial was not
public people would have said oh well
you know the court system is against
women and all that but because we can
see it I knew Johnny was innocent early
because I had Source himself with Amber
her I knew she was a narcissist just by
the things she would do but most people
were fooled by her because she was
pretty and had a smile and she just
claimed victimhood but once it came out
Johnny Depp his case was impivital for
all men and all women to finally see
that yes there are women and the a large
a large number of women who are lying
and the paternity court Mori if why
don't women why don't you as a woman say
correlate say those women on paternity
court and Maury who the father is not it
there's been women who've been tested 30
men and they still have not found the
father we talk about accountability
right because the modern woman would
prefer to lie then take accountability
so with the Amber Heard Johnny Depp case
she preferred to lie than to be seen
because I've always said that women have
a perception right that they want to
keep up they want to be seen a certain
way and so what it is is that for women
image is all of is everything right and
so with Amber ERD she um she didn't want
her image to be destroyed with the women
that go on the Maury Show and they I'm
telling you they go crazy he should have
been doing this before the DNA test
comes out by the way they're going crazy
because what they're trying to keep an
image right the problem is the reason
why MTR I was talking about okay DNA
test should be mandatory the reason why
they won't do it is because women's
image would be destroyed women want an
image in this society and their image is
going to be destroyed so what they would
prefer to do is lie because there are
many people most people believe that
women are quite innocent believe that
they're ones always they're the ones
that are always a victim right what will
happen is their image will be destroyed
and they'll be seen for who they are and
they don't want it yeah
one of the things that I learned in
doing content in this space is like when
I think about like the reason that
feminism is where it is right now and
the ideals as what it is is that it's
all a power play it's all it's all about
power
at the end of it at the beginning of it
and at the end of it it's about power
why would you consistently want to be a
victim
to act like you are a victim in a
society and talk about this patriarchy
and talk about your endless oppression
when you're in the freest cleanness
lack of poverty lack of homelessness
lack of lack of and
the most abundant version of that
society that has ever existed in the
history of mankind today what rights do
you not have that I have
but that's what we've convinced them
today as if it actually exists so they
think they could just get away with the
privilege of not being accountable
because of all the structures that are
put into place one thing you guys
mentioned before earlier was about Maori
think about the concept of more this is
why so many women today are incapable of
understanding the word accountability
when they look at the different
structures within our society today the
concept of Mori is she contests six to
ten men but she'll never get booed ever
she gets clapped she can come out up on
stage and never get booed but they'll
boo all six of the guys even if they
were never the father they'll move every
last one of them you as a young boy I'm
sitting here watching this [__] like
damn man ain't [__] man ain't [__] and
that's the [__] that I was looking at
the content men ain't [__] because of
course they had the dudes on the side
said boo or yay if the woman came out so
it goes deep it goes so deep and what
we've been conditioned to believe it
that's why hold up that's why there's so
many women today that are just incapable
of seeing behind the trees
they just don't see it they literally
don't say they blind to it but they were
conditioned to be blind to it but it
makes them a better consumer so but you
know what MJ I'm sorry to call you right
but you know what happens when they do
get found out to be lying they get
consoled oh they run away
oh it's okay so what you what it is is
that there's no accountability me and
MTR know right if a guy does something
and it's wrong and it goes tits up
there's an accountability there right
there's accountability right there women
get consoled they get mother cuddled
they get told that it's okay don't worry
about it so then she does what she goes
and does it again yet because she never
learned the lesson there was no real
consequence
consoled by men and women men and women
exactly there's always a bailout I mean
even the church I mean it it tells the
men to date Born Again virgins
can I say this on more even if you watch
it the women will run they will go
automatically the woman feminist cheer
when he comes out and all these men are
booed she will run off the show
screaming and crying going crazy and
Mori will chastise the man that child
still needs a father she didn't mean it
you know you should still be nice to her
um
but if the man says that's not my child
I'm not gonna they shame him and it's
gonna be that what do you think about
that like all of this that we've said
and we've said a lot I'm sorry you would
have thought earlier I'm just gonna let
you go really quick my thought was so
what's the solution right like men talk
about we want to be forward focusing we
want to reach a goal we want to end the
solution right and so back to the
proposal earlier it's the five to ten
percent of men right we've all agreed
that men should be leading right but men
have taken a passive seat to allow women
to the the plot the platform has
switched women are being men we're out
here in the streets and we're doing what
we're doing women
we chose to to be but we chose to do
that we talked to do so so who whose
fault is it the men or the person making
the choice we made the choice to sleep
though where did that come from because
back in the day when men were bleeding
we're in control of sex they're in
control of relationships okay but where
did that come from it came from a lack
of Father sitting their daughters down
to her Point she brought up a very good
point and I I guarantee you if this 80
of women had men what do you mean why
but why because there's incentive
structures in place that allow women to
take the father out of the home with no
consequence and women and women
absolutely women in the last hundred
years or absolutely since the 60s yeah
so again women chose to do that we
didn't have to take those structures up
ABS okay so we kind of were forced to
that's another no we were not ma'am no
no no no we were we were not forced if
you weren't going to get a check if your
husband was in the house and you had to
provide for him and the kids we
absolutely were forced to take the false
narrative
so if we go back into this it is is
third wave feminism that actually caused
this and we talked about it earlier I
was talking to Pearl about it about
Cosmopolitan magazine and how they
actually there were it made money to
create in the black family structure
specifically because this is this is
where the problem really lies in in in
the world in in the U.S I will say I
don't know how it is in the UK
um but our family structure they they
purposely destroyed our family structure
um because it made them money
um we can go into even government
welfare government cheese uh there was a
surplus of farmers having cows they
needed to get they needed to make money
government grants and able to somebody
needed to get this this cheese so to get
this milk get the food that they had a
surplus in or it would go rotten and
these Farmers would not make money this
is layered upon layers of layers that
were systematic so to say we did not
have a choice we chose we chose greed we
chose a bag over a man we chose to not
our children we would rather have a
bunch of money than have our children
have a father in the home
no one no no you have to know the
history this is I'm proven speaking
history we're not able to work and
provide for their families
they couldn't stay in the house if they
were there that's false then how are
they going to feed the children the
children were fat women were greedy
because they were coming from the
government
black women wanted to be like white
women in the Cosmopolitan magazine the
woman who ran who started Cosmopolitan
magazine the main editor she's now a
Catholic and she repented from what she
did she said we were teaching women
because we wanted all women to feel that
we had a gripe with white men and so
yeah this is public knowledge you look
it up on YouTube yes absolutely they
wanted black women to also be part of
their movement in other races because it
wasn't enough the black woman and the
black man had to stay together in the
U.S because it was the only way for us
to overcome what they did was with Cosmo
with a lot these were women that would
say you know what this is a single woman
moved to New York she's sleeping with
different men she has their life she has
her own money her education she's
getting these jobs these women were
promoting promiscuity and living a
certain lifestyle when they were all
married they were all lying and making
up these people because it was supposed
to be a fantasy magazine but women were
taken as gospel and real and so what
happened is black women saw the white
woman as as Pinnacle because we're not
going into colorism and all that that's
not what this show is about but we saw
the white woman as what to strive for as
black women we're saying these white
women are free these white women are
independent these white women don't need
no man I don't need mine he's not doing
enough he's not good enough as a black
man when our entire lives how we came
out of everything we did in the U.S was
through the black man and black women
coming together so we allowed these
women and these corporations who wanted
to make money off of our backs and they
knew that we had a a a a a
insecurity about being dark about being
black and we wanted to strive to the
higher societies because white women
were seen as the highest so we think we
want to be like white women get our
education do this do that when those
women were lying even to other white
women they were lying to us as black
women so then the government stepped in
there's a whole documentaries about this
on black history and I mean black
historians will not refute this this is
what we all know as gospel in our
communities so what you're saying right
here is black children when we were
being provided for but it wasn't enough
we wanted to be like white women and we
had greed in our eyes we had we had Envy
in our eyes and we're like I don't need
no black man I can do better I Can Do
Bad All By Myself And so our children
it's a false and everything our children
were not eating our children were eating
we want it better and yeah because the
idea
wait wait so the idea that it's a money
thing and that like women had to take
the government assistant because the men
weren't taking enough money or weren't
making enough money is that what you're
saying so I think it's great that we can
now in our liberated sense and now that
we have the knowledge and understand it
right we can definitely look back vision
is 2020 right and say we would do stuff
different in that time that was the
narrative in the picture is that what
you're saying that is what I'm saying
I'm just okay I just want to sorry
you're saying the men weren't making
enough money so the women had to take
the government assistance yes so but
even even wait wait wait wait wait oh my
God wait wait sorry so even even then
they had a higher standard of living
than most people did in all of human
history so how is it an excuse when
you're living better than most people
did in all of human history okay so I'm
speaking specifically for the black
families right and so back then when men
were living at home they were not able
to be employable right and so they would
leave why weren't they employable
because they to her she everything she
said is 100 factual right and if we knew
that that was a narrative then of course
we wouldn't have fallen for it right but
because they were trying to divide the
black family they would say men to
provide for your family or things like
that we don't want you to be there
because we know that you're a leader is
in the impact of that so how can we
divide that we're going to give you good
qualifying jobs if you're in the home
but then the woman how can I provide and
how can I do this if he's not in the
home they would take the government if
we all know it's a scam now absolutely
but back in the day that was the reality
to get a good paying job to try to pay
for your family be employable right you
thought you had to not live in the
household so you agree yeah I wasn't
that I wasn't agreeing I couldn't
elaborate on it right and everything she
said was a hundred percent so right but
but listen though if you agree
then why
would they take that solution because
it's almost as if Cosmo created this
fantasy but the black women attached
themselves to that fantasy to overthrow
the patreon today but black men were
never a part of the patriarchy so what
would y'all try to be independent from
listen I'm not saying it was right I
can't go back then and speak so then
hold them accountable I agree with that
I've always said we should hold women
accountable this evening right but today
we're still doing the same narrative
right we're still selling city girls and
being out here and being flown out and
women are still buying it yes
whose fault is it for buying it exactly
I would challenge one thing that you
said when you say that if we all agree
that there's 80 percent of women that
are out here running the streets and
then there's a five to ten percent of
men that are taking advantage of that I
reject the idea that the focus should be
on the small percentage of men that are
running the streets when we have an
overabundance of women that are not
acting accordingly I would say let's at
least get that down to five to ten
percent of women are running the streets
five to ten percent of men are running
the streets and then look at them
equally but as long as we have the scale
so tipped that women are allowing this I
say let's clean our own house first
before we point the fingers yeah but
that's why that's that's why I said you
come back to the the one percent because
we understand and we talk about it all
this all the time on the show women make
80 of consumer buying decisions right so
that means you can sell anything to
women who are the people in power that
know this because I'm not in power and I
know this so the people are in power
notice everything is sold to women they
sold in feminism now they sell them city
girls they can sell them I don't know
they can sell them juice tomorrow I
don't know whatever it is women can be
sold stuff so the so like I said the
point of of I guess my conclusion is
that women are not supposed to lead
right they're not supposed men are
supposed to lead the society and men are
supposed to start selling things to men
they won't get as much money but they're
gonna have to start selling things to
men which is why podcasts like this
exist we know that the podcasts like
your spell is not in the majority of
podcasts and many people don't listen to
it you have a you have a niche because
you because your audience is probably
mostly men men don't buy like women by
they're not gonna they're not gonna be
on it they're not gonna be the shade
Barrel shade borrower crew or whatever
it's so easy to sell to women we need to
stop selling to women and then
I might get deep but I think we need to
start separating ourselves from certain
types of people yeah go ahead write the
system right certain types of people but
listen right women are the problem I 100
agree with you Maggie right I wasn't
saying don't focus on that 80 of women
we but it's a balancing fact you can't
just focus that's extremity right when
you go to one side and you focus heavy
it doesn't it ends up going back up we
don't balance why do we balance it when
the problem is unbalanced because
unfortunately like why would we why
would we balance it when women are
causing most of the problems because
it's scientific right and just nature
right when you're balancing things out
it's scientific and it's neat I don't
I'm I'm okay go ahead go ahead the
balancing beam right if you go to one
extremity the other one's gonna go up so
just in approaching we have to be
careful to balance it out this is just
how it works guys let her go ahead
that's just how it works naturally right
and honestly how do we get here so I'm
just not understanding what you're
saying with the beam so how does us like
talking about women hey women we need to
we need to step it up and then the women
will always come in and say well but
don't forget about the men and we're
like hey you know what we can deal with
that when we when we get the women
because this is a way bigger problem
than the men why why is that an issue
like how does that how does that make
the problem bigger
I agree we should definitely focus on
the women they need to take
accountability I'm not no I I know but
I'm saying what what about that when we
get hyper focused on that and we solely
focus on that it causes a chain reaction
of the opposite to then happen
that's just it's a chain reaction that's
that's how do we get there we started
focusing on like men having all the
right how does it make a chain reaction
so I'm just I'm just I wanna because
this is very Broad and a lot of times
like as women we say things that are so
broad that they don't like mean anything
okay and so and so if I'm saying hey
women step it up let's do better okay
with this is a problem that's a problem
that's a problem that's a problem that's
a problem we could say okay the men have
this one problem we have five why don't
we tackle one two three four exactly
what how does that make problem over
here bigger so if we have a balancing
beam they have one we have five right
right and so we're trying to take are we
taking five away from here just to get
it to one and one so it can be balanced
I mean maybe are we trying to just take
one and like five away and then he goes
over here right but technically
even if we use the balancing beam right
and like then this would be heavier than
the men's problem the only way to
balance it out is to focus on the
heavier problem first exactly and even
with this analogy like that doesn't I
would argue I think that's feelings we
might be surprised that what we want the
men to change may actually self-correct
if women started acting differently men
are going to holler men are going to try
men are gonna shoot their shot but if we
don't allow someone to have access
without being worthy of it then they'll
either go to someone that will allow it
but if the next girl says you know what
no these are my standards they'll go on
to the next person and if the next girl
says these are my standards men will
change their approach based on the
results that they get but we keep giving
it away so easily there's no incentive
for a man to change so I would argue we
focus on the 80 let's get our house in
order and we may look up and see there's
always going to be that small amount of
people who who are going to try and you
know get whatever they can for free but
I think men would definitely step them
up step up I think we um we should give
them more credit Megan you're a quiet
storm tonight you are quiet
I told you I'm gonna Read Super chats
for a second good um Maggie you are a
natural-born YouTuber you guys should
check out her Channel thank you um okay
guys um all super chats are gonna be
read tonight
um so make sure you guys send super
chats uh blessing what are we saving for
right now blessings always got equipment
he's trying to buy just bleed me dry
this is a nice studio right guys
it's all thanks to the super chats and
blessing bleeding me dry you know just
gone broke out here because of blessings
so it sounds super tight oh yeah we want
a kick out camera
[Laughter]
um okay verse records um white white
sweater just want to be smart open your
ears Lisa the housewife wife Maggie the
Lioness training these hyenas hashtag
are you a wife bright and solutions
people Solutions I'm Lewis Hannah when
it was open to Black Americans black
women chose not to have men in the house
for a check hence Choice welfare was
created by FDR's a wife or widowed white
women due to their husbands dying at war
that is why men were not allowed in the
household Wilson that's not what you're
saying initially liar Marcus The Need to
Be Right is real Marcus Melanie King has
spitting too many bars right now fire
Emoji fire Emoji fire Emoji fire Emoji
marriage causes divorce I'm Johnny Depp
lost his DV case in the UK courts the
only reason he's seen as innocent is
because of the USA courts the UK courts
are unreliable bias and the average guy
can't afford Justice Lu KC 20 a Melanie
is a Melanie for the W on this one the
cosmo fact is 100 accurate they were
told to write articles like they were
writing them for Playboy Ryan a cooking
fire Emoji fire Emoji 100 emoji facet
cooking tonight shout out to the panel
and all the special guests is getting
hot Brighton what's the solution for men
and for women what is the cure how can
we be better instead of focusing on the
problem what is the solution
dc-081 I have a friend who already
planned how he would delete himself if
he's ever falsely accused by a woman
because defamation will ruin any man
lukc 20 amen MTR D the believe all women
statement is faulty in my opinion it's
making women not accountable for their
own poor decisions Frank uh Frank major
one co-worker said I sexually harassed
her sent all the money in exchange of
sex when she had a car accident I was
nice to her and sent her money to get an
Uber she reported me to HR growth um
thanks Mel for bringing up the paternity
discussion came all hey Mel men aren't
price conscious it's because you spend
all our money on fancy glass jars of
Pebbles from Ikea we like to spend money
too PJ Cornell the punishment for
lodging a false accusation should be
identical to the punishment for the
crime the defendant was accused of LP
Berkshire speaking from a professor
National standpoint it is illegal to
make false claims in the states they
just won't prosecute Clark W false
accusers need to do prison time
Aaron Laura a much love to Maggie and
MTR great panel and discussions thank
you for putting this together jpt blue
the God I have had way more women than I
was supposed to because of the daddy
issues and I was offered kind words
and I offered kind words we got to do
better educating and loving these women
and at an early age will of de-simping
for Melanie and shout out to MTR I'm
Abdul Malik the adult needs to be
self-accountable but our fathers
brothers and uncles need to be held
accountable for not protecting their
girls before they're women BJ olupa
women tend to give each other
justification for their action with a
selfish intention of self-preservation
when they decide to do the very same
action they are justifying sister code
Lou Casey a W for MTR Keith a generation
single mothers and babies having babies
we are now seeing the results we have
grandmothers in their 40s who have
daughters in their 30s who have
daughters just turning 18 they all want
the same men 90 free-toe bye women will
sleep with married men over a mama's boy
Lou kc20 yes oh W for Maggie
um Shelton Ward let's get active John
Quinn to refer to the gentleman with the
glasses I agree I think the reason
Society caters to women is now is
society is simping it's taking a
microchasm of simping relationships and
Society of Sims 90 Frito pie Proverbs
tells us no one is angry at a beggar for
stealing food but Justice is blind
period
um JT coins so cool to see Maggie Alex
sentellis hey Pearl so happy to see
Melanie and Zara together on a show
question how can women scream patriarchy
even when we when men are becoming women
every day at the end of the day no
matter how educated or high level a
woman will act typical and emotional
like Melanie AKA Karen hairstyle 93 Joe
pie you're in a room with your parent
you're going to hold them accountable
for your childhood who would be easier
to talk to Mom or Dad Lisa the housewife
Maggie is a wife are you
um I don't know Luke Pearl have you
cleaned that laptop yet
a great panel
um let's now let's do all the top toxic
people from the past and see how they
react to each other yelling over each
other I'm 90 free topai Melanie should
fight Destiny take it easy on him
um I'm gonna refresh this really quick
just to see the new ones that came in
guys like the video also we're doing a
meet up Sunday in London a at flat iron
Square 5 30 if you guys want to come
uh let me do and sign up for our email
list it's in the description it's going
to give you updates and if anything
changes with the time or the place so
sign up for the email list
MTG um gaming Bob personal
accountability should apply equally to
men and to women I love your
level-headedness Pearl men tuition shout
out to Pearl MTR and Melanie glad to see
you guys all together hope to meet you
real soon you've pushed myself and my
co-host to make more content and step up
our over quality overall Christian Drake
why are women trying to convince men to
be weak that's not what they want um
DMACC MTR and Mrs King way to rep the US
Chris thank you for the Super Chat
Winton to great
um the great prophet once said become
the best version of yourself to make the
viscous innards moist
um Genesis 4K of pearl is red pill
um the PJ Cornell the older woman is
exactly right I learned to treat Western
women as a one-night stand material Earl
only now I'm engaged to an immigrant
woman the only rational that is only
rational is a man in the west sentience
a hundred dollar Super Chat
[Applause]
we missed you on the channel oh I know
yes we all knows yes yes
um was like the first big super chat it
was actually really encouraging I was
really frustrated at the time he was
like the first base early Super Chat to
the show
um just stopping by to show support to
this intellectually opulent panel sorry
I don't know what the word means um
respect to melon Pearl Pearl Melanie
Sarah
um and suedo gamer um gents in the chat
be well focus on yourself
he's talking about me
um focus on yourself and excellent let
today's Times Forge you into strong man
never let 304s distract you um mega
people adapt to their environment okay
can I can I oh sorry yeah I just wanted
to say one thing I know a lot of our
conversation is focused in on
accountability for women but at least
like I said earlier like if you're a
dude and you're unaccountable out here I
have I'm not sorry for you like I'm not
sorry for you I don't care at all and
guess what the world doesn't care right
the world doesn't care if you fail and
then you don't pick up the pieces the
world doesn't care if she cheat on you
and you didn't improve on yourself the
world doesn't care if you're scared of
failure the world doesn't care the world
doesn't care they will never care you
have to be a man within your own right
within your own masculinity to pick up
the pieces solution for yourself to
create the life that you want
the world doesn't care they care about
women They Don't Care About Us all right
so work on yourself and continue
keys to the game
keys to the game this is your British
accent just now
because Sarah wants to come to the USA
what's up I'll be there man I'll be
there man
he's good okay so question who created
unrealistic dating expectations we have
today where did it come from
oh that's a good question the women
women I mean let's not pretend I mean
what happens is women will go through
trauma make poor decisions and what they
do instead of changing and growing they
will say well I have to level up and I
have to pick I have to they add more
standards to what their the men that
they choose instead of saying
something's wrong with me I need to take
accountability and the choices that I've
made they will turn around and say no
the men need to jump through higher
Hoops now I come now with more trauma
baggage probably kids and everything
else but these men still I'm now as I
age I'm getting better like fine wine
I'm getting better like wine and so they
think that they keep raising these
standards and Men across the board
almost every man I talk to they for a
woman whose mind is right they were
lower looks they were lower in every
category I have yet to meet a woman out
the bag that will say that they will
lower their standards to get a certain
type of quality the only time a woman
lowers her standards in terms of looks
and character and all of this stuff that
they claim is when he has money I'm
going to offer a different perspective
sorry I'm gonna play Devil's Advocate
yeah I was about to and the thing is is
that like if you look at patriarchal
regimes across our world right now women
can't create anything without a man yeah
nothing they can't create anything they
can't just step out of nowhere and just
create feminism feminism has to be
supplanted by men it has to be
undefended but what person but what
percent of men partic part took in
making those laws versus what percent of
women participated in it listen I think
I think a lot of men I think I think
listen at the end of the day there's
things get shifted and changed due to
money and men wanting vagina that's why
they say [__] runs the world because of
simp ass men that can't control a
goddamn eggplant [__] don't change in
here without men [__] will never change
in those other patriarchal regimes
unless men allow it to can I tell you
all the inventions that make women's
lives easier now were created by men
tampons were created by a man women can
vote because of men no actually because
men joined that and so a lot of times
we'll say that men are this way men are
that but they never give voice to the
men that actually created things and
enjoined you know with women to to help
create things so it's like they just
throw men and men don't have a desire to
put women down like they don't even
think of us in that way like it feels
good
oh let's talk about it so they don't
have like I think women have this idea
that men just are thinking about how
they can they can you know oppress us
and and do all this to us when every
every even the C-section created by a
man to save women's lives if you
actually go through history the majority
of things that actually benefit women
today that we take for granted and and
the same woman will blame a man for for
getting pregnant but to say another man
created the C-section so you and your
baby wouldn't lose their life and so we
we don't think of these things but we I
don't know it's just emotional talk we
just say men are just men are the blame
for everything let's just let's put it
out there to kind of answer your
question right
to throw a different Javier in there
in there change the game when men
decided that they've got a load of money
in their pocket and they decided to
start flying women out
and they decided to start paying for
everything for women because they had it
what did what did Lil Wayne said it
ain't tricking if you got it yeah it is
that's what he said right he said it's
not tricking if you've got it so these
rich rappers who were still simps but
they had a lot of money started to
change the game because a lot of women
started to go to these concerts go to
these rappers and these rappers would
pay for everything they'd fly them out
they'd do all of this kind of stuff and
then those women start to think oh
yeah okay well so-and-so flew me out so
and so gave me money so and so done that
for me and so rich simp men also had a
hand do you know it wasn't the rappers
it was the R B singers well them too
whoever they started at the RnB started
do you think it's really simping if he
gets sex out of it yeah because I was
done you know what I mean like is it
really simple to drink Hey listen wait
wait wait so if money if no money is
nothing to Drake and he he spends money
to fly a girl out like the money's
nothing to him and he gets sex with this
girl he wanted to have sex with yeah and
I still think it starts with the women
because they have to accept it there's
plenty of Sims that get pity viscous
innards yeah but but people but people
like Drake people like Drake who have
money he might have game right but when
you got money you don't necessarily need
game you just got money right so a poor
guy who's got no but you said it was
rich simps who did it and I said is he
really a simp if he's flying her out you
know yeah I would say he was I I would
say it was like there's there's nothing
in my mind how much money I've got
that's gonna say oh yeah let me fly
around why would you fly a vagina out
with his vagina right there
[Music]
and if you said if all you had to do was
tell your PA hey I want this girl at
this time pull like pull the money on my
credit cards
but that's why I said it's spoiling the
market so so those guys types of guys
they spoiled the market
yeah
how many are rappers I feel like that's
the same argument to say well it's these
these five percent of guys and it's not
even five percent of guys who are
rappers it's a very small handful of
guys who are rappers who actually do
that I would it expands Beyond it
and why do we say that they spoil the
market instead of the women spoil
themselves
he didn't spoil [__]
gets thrown around without like a
tangible definition so like personally I
don't think that if you're a billionaire
you buy a chicken or even a millionaire
you fly a chick out with like a you know
150 ticket round-trip on Spirit that'll
make you no goddamn set at all okay and
you're not even tricking either because
the average average day nowadays in
America right
[Music]
anyway uh case in point
um I just don't think that it's
necessarily um I understand your point
my G but I don't think it's necessarily
A simp stuff to me Sim is petalizing a
woman uh thinking that she is the prize
without her proving anything right like
just thinking that you just owe her the
world Diamonds and Pearls she deserves
this and she hasn't proved
again isn't necessarily mean paying for
a a a trip for her to come over here and
Slob On My Knob like cold
yeah I would just offer that and I guess
I would ask the question so the women
that are in this group that are getting
food out are they the same pool of women
that would date an average man it goes
back to that 80 20. are they there's
always going to be you know the man with
a lot of money the woman that he's going
to want to you know pick for this day of
the week but we're talking about
everyday average like I can't take you
on a date because you have ridiculous
expectations is it that same group I
think I think average women have because
average women are accessed by those top
percent of men right
um those average women can get Effects
by this top percent of men because I was
top percent of men don't feel any way to
have sex with a woman who's a two to a
woman who's a 10 right so what it does
is that it spoils the market because
these women who are fives think that
they deserve what a 10 gets right
because they were accessed by a 10 by a
top tier man they were accessed by him
and then now she runs around thinking oh
those average dudes are way they're weak
they're whack no that's who you are they
set their new barometer because a man
will sleep with you
um who is higher up you think that
that's your new set point like a lot of
women will raise their standard well now
because this man slept with me he just
was a f boy he was playing around but
now I can attain that type of man as a
husband as who will wife me and they
actually will start to get run through
by these men or try to enable put down
average men who are on their level and
look look at them as lower and the
reality is that causes you to lose and I
mean even this whole conversation is not
to put women down down it is not to it's
to say listen there are guys who are up
at this level they are sleeping with you
girl but they are not going to wife you
they're sleeping with you because it's
easy to do you should be upset with them
not us for telling you the truth but
they you raise your standard to
something that's not you will never get
the results that you want and then we
want you to get the results so I'm I
have a question
um for the older women on the panel
um when do you think women start to
lower their standards if ever
at what age
I didn't want to believe it when I heard
Kevin Samuel say 60 because I thought
that was so far off but I really do
believe because we have this thing you
know black don't crack or whatever I'm
still 47 in three years I'll be half a
hundred I should move differently than
someone that's 27 so I would say women
mistakenly think
I can still compete in that Arena so I
shouldn't have to settle and then you
end up in your 50s and 60s alone and
then you say okay I'll just be happy to
have anyone she's she's telling the
truth so I'm 41. and this is the reality
I I have young guys I mean like young
like Ballers NBA like guys who are we
like early 20s who will hit me up want
to take me out and all of this and a lot
of women who still can carry a little
bit as they get older they're still in
shape they're getting hit up by these
young guys and you think you still have
it because these guys will want to sleep
with you they'll even take you out there
I mean they'll even buy you something to
do they're not going to marry you and a
lot of women just like the glamor of it
and they feel like they still got it and
they don't realize these guys are just
using you for easy sex and so because
they're sleeping with you and they're
attracted to you that translates in your
mind that I got it like I'm still in the
game I know women who are like 50 and
older who actually look amazing like no
lie like I know these women have women
in my family who look this way and if
they wanted to most of them in my family
are married but if they wanted to they
they could attract they're 50 they can
attract a 30 year old guy and so it is
not until they hit where it starts to
crack and and guys are just like man 60
uh they can't do that that's six that
six puts a hurt even if a guy wanted to
I was just gonna say they can attract
him but they can't keep him and
ultimately that's what we want at the
end of the day we're not just supposed
to be out here floating around from man
to man we are supposed to be tethered
and attached and belong to someone and I
think that's normal and that's natural
we just have to do a better job of
making the distinction between attention
and intention that's right sexual sexual
is sexual attraction versus relationship
intention and a lot of women cannot tell
the difference so I'm curious you said
you're 21 yeah would you say what
they're talking about do you see that
with your friends where they'll sleep
with someone that's out of their league
or that someone famous will DM them yeah
and you know it happens it's happened to
me but because I know they're rappers
footballers basketball players I'm just
not into that because I know that
they're not going to be available to me
so but my friends on the other hand
they're more
yeah will they um fly out to someone
where they don't know yeah I'm curious
and you don't have to say this if you
don't want to how many guys has a girl
your age slept with usually like not you
but just in general
um
now around 15. oh my God are you 21
so she's not even 21 yet guys and you
would say the average girl I'm not
saying me personally it's only been one
but yeah but girls your age it's like 15
to 20. yeah plus and how many how many
did were they in relationships with
none it's mainly situationships now so
you know shout out to feminism and would
you would you agree that it's like
mostly the same guys that they're all
sleeping with yeah but then every time
someone does them run like they start
catching feelings the sky is like okay
well I don't want a relationship with
you they're like okay I'm gonna up my
standards wow and then to wear why do I
love her so much guys she's so pretty
too thank you sorry go okay keep talking
sorry she is so cute yeah they um they
up their standards and
when there's someone that like maybe a
rapper footballer messages them they're
just like they hop on it and then it's
like a cycle the same thing happens
where that guy just doesn't want her for
what she wants and do most of the time
do the men tell the women up front that
they're not looking for anything yeah
but they still believe that I can change
it yeah feminism
would you agree that it's mostly on the
women then because the guy said up front
what they're looking for yeah and why
did you make a different Choice what
made you be in a relationship with a lot
of your friends are in the streets
because I just I you know I I'm very
traditional I want marriage and I just
don't I'm just not into the whole rapper
scene I'm very private I like to keep
myself to myself so I'm just not not
into it yeah older women we have to
protect it protect her I feel like
you're like my daughter I believe
son you ain't gonna feminism
okay don't put that on me that's your
trauma ah I'm protecting baby right here
reach out I will talk to her absolutely
that's my job feminism has
disguised female empowerment through
sexual Liberation and acted like that
thing is the damn truth how it's
delusional do you create this idea that
these guys are telling you this is not
what I want and you try to change the
damn Minds that mean that makes no damn
sense to me at the end of the day you
need to look at your results
and if you are 15 guys deep
15 15
large sweating oh God young men you know
that's love humping that's love
aggressively okay
you know what I mean
that's why they demonetized me
sad is it's so important for young women
to speak up like that and even what
Maggie is saying it's almost like you
can you can you can see the wisdom you
can see that coming out and what will
happen is with a girl like her if her
mind wasn't right or if she wasn't open
to things she would be influenced to go
to the streets and so many other young
women are influencing their friends to
go to the streets because they want to
be validated in what they're doing they
don't want somebody doing better being
wifed up because then then I have to
look at myself and like there's a bit of
jealousy that she has a boyfriend maybe
even put your boyfriend down I've cut
off a lot of people but I actually don't
have any friends even my cousins I've
had to cut them off completely wow
because they've they're going through
hard times like
my cousin's been with someone for six
years and they're not in a relationship
and he cheats and he just uses her then
they look at me and they get really
jealous and that's why I just had to cut
them off but that's so dangerous right
because we need Community we need so
please connect with her and get that
mentorship and get that yes because we
need that we need people who are going
to reach down and educate us and show us
that it's different we need men who are
going to look at us and say hey that
ain't cool don't be out here giving it
to these boys don't be doing this right
and that's why I keep going to the whole
it's a circle of effect right it's not
just focusing on one end it's it's a
role that both are called to play yes we
absolutely have to take accountability
as a woman and I love that at 21 I'm you
know approaching 21
um that you are doing that that you are
mature that this is wisdom talking if we
go out on these streets even in America
I can't come across an average 21 year
old who thinks like you do that is so
rare you are a unicorn in today's
society we don't exist right so I love
that that's why I would say there are
more our husbands today when a man finds
a woman whose mind is right and talks
like that even young she is so valuable
out here even like the a man will will
let go of a lot of things I talk to a
lot of high-value men in terms of what
they're looking for and I say will you
will you like you know I don't need a
10. I will take a seven I will even take
a six I will take a woman if she has the
right mind and I know I can trust her
and I'm safe with her and she's going to
be a good mother and a good wife I'll
take that all day over these IG models
who are just worth nothing and and and
these men they can run through them and
it just becomes boring it just becomes
they're intrigued by a woman who has
character and quality and a lot of these
young women are not understanding this
even men that you think are absolutely
for the street if they come again
they've come across character and
quality they are just like they cannot
they feel like it's a unicorn but there
are more men who are ready than there
are how many young women talk like this
how many young men are actually virgins
compared to young women who are 21
they're not women can get sex everywhere
that's why the body count is high have
you ever spoken to your friends but
maybe that's not the best like path to
go down and how do they react they're
like well they just they don't listen
then the thing is they get hurt they run
to me and then the next day they're
talking to them again
and then it's kind of dragging me down
and it's the energy and I just don't
want that energy one of the reasons why
we don't listen to women out here guys
okay because uh women will say a lot of
things like you said they would say oh I
hate him he's this he's that next week
they're back they're back with him why
did they do that though girl you know
because women are led by their emotions
and they want validation for men right
well they're led by their emotions
if a guy gets cheated on right his love
it kicks in he said okay what is it like
what did she do how did it go down oh my
God that makes me feel sick oh I can't
be around it anymore a woman
is she wants that like you said she
wants that validation she's emotionally
attached to somebody and she will let
that lead and she will she doesn't think
about the things that men think about
when when they get cheated on I'd like
to answer your question why why do women
do that I think it's because women we
just want everything and we wanna we
wanna you know as women you know we want
to think that we're who's that Ronaldo
guy's wife what's her face that was
working at a shoe store yeah yeah do you
know what I'm talking about anyone know
her name yeah
Georgina Georgina you know I think women
in general were narcissistic and we all
think that we're more important than we
are and we also think that we can change
men as she said and we all think we're
CR whatever Ronaldo so even if a man
hasn't wife the last 50 girls 100 girls
200 women we're all just think that
we're special and that we're gonna be
the 201st that just changes him and
occasionally you know there's a Ronaldo
chick that gets lucky and then all the
girls point at the Sierras and the
Ronaldo checks and just say well they
did it so I can do it but
you don't look like her right so you
won't have that outcome and then when
you try to tell him that
I just don't listen and do it again yeah
I don't think it's even determined on
women like a lot of times when a man is
ready for a wife the next woman that
comes along that meets the criteria that
he's looking for he will get married
it's it may not even dependent on
because she's so special it's just that
she's meeting certain criteria that he
can work with and when a man is ready
men own marriage they own relationship
we own sex so if a man wants marriage he
is tired of the streets he wants a wife
and his mind is set on that the next
girl that comes along that offers at
least a large portion at least the
majority of the things that he's looking
for he will settle down and that's why
women will say why is he with her she's
not even that fine she's not that bad
his ex-girlfriend looked better and we
will start talking about the looks we
don't even women talk about like why are
men so concerned about looks we will dog
a woman out who is with a man that we
want who is high value and say well
she's not as fine and like people down
the street like my neighbor looks better
I look better than her she's not even a
bad B but yet we will get mad at men and
say they focus on looks but that we
don't understand the psychology of men
when they're tired men can just go right
now of all of us women in here it's a
dry season we just we need some d
to the streets probably even to the
dudes in here
we can go outside and say listen Maggie
let's just run it
but no this is what women are if we go
out if I go outside if all of us women
go outside right now and we just walk up
to random dudes and like listen
you can come to my hotel you can come to
my room come to my apartment I I need
some D let's let's get it in we can just
get it we can go to a club and just we
can wear a sign and say come get this
and we will get it if a man wore that
women are not running up to that man
we're scared we're running away we're
like terrified it will some men be
terrified yes but for the most part men
are gonna come flocking lining up for
that and it comes to marriage if a man
came on and said listen I need a wife I
want a woman I want to be dedicated to
her I want to I'm going to be faithful I
want to do that women will come running
out of the woodwork so men own
relationship and marriage and whoever
comes next if you if you line up enough
don't get okay I'm gonna tell God I want
a wife
I messed up I messed up
um I'm gonna take a second to read super
chats really quick
um Aaron ultimately the main goal for
every relationship should be marriage
and kids if you sleep around don't be
upset if they don't stick around Ally no
marriage means no divorce I'm lobbying
to make marriage illegal only side
chicks can vote
they call me Mr bibs I'll give you
another five dollars just because I love
the way the young lady speaks and they
do make a Jeep for women they call it
Jeep Liberty um compare comparative
historian Evolution designed men to
sleep around and women not to this is
the heart of the problem
uh bright and nothing good is ever easy
um come pies actually I read this super
chat I thought was actually really good
or interesting how can the system be
changed if the contributors of the
broken system do not want it to change
the top men won't change it they're
winning the women won't change it they
have a deck full of get out of jail free
cards instead of accountability Emily
Ziegler thank you for Pearl for helping
me be a better wife and mother to my
kids also I get a WooHoo for finishing
six months of chemo let's give her
[Applause]
casely 20 Melanie the camera angle is
not too forgiving
um Ally soy boys make it easy for top
Gees to use their women and discard in
the states of the USA if Ray Ray gets a
married woman pregnant the husband has
to pay child support Who let that
legislation pass controversial videos
happy belated birthday Kevin Samuels PJ
Cornell I'm grateful to the men who want
I'm grateful to the men who fly women
out for showing us the 304s they really
are controversial videos where is Auntie
Jenny she's missing out Brighton on the
chat is necessary God bless y'all Ling
Mel and pearl are so damn fine um see
Rob the great Kevin Samuels was
crucified for this content but always
said that men and women are better
together yes Paradox Northern Canadian
Lumberjack here wrong chat I think I'm
stricker17 only women can fix the
problem them cam from TMR radio actually
when the initial unemployment rate went
up actually the initial unemployment
rate went up for all Races all women
chose the government assistance however
once the unemployment rate went back
down only black women chose to keep the
check over their men OB OJ bees what do
you think about the whole passport bro
situation and modern Western women's
slating Asian women on MTG gaming
personal accountability should apply
equally to men and women I love your
level-headedness Pearl men tuition shout
out to Pearl MTR and Melanie glad to see
you all together hope to meet you guys
real soon you've pushed me and all and
my co-host to make quality of quality
content yeah let me just refresh really
quick to make sure that there's no other
ones also guys like the video a like is
free there's over 5 000 people in the
chat so we should have at least 2 500
likes so make sure that you are liking
the video MB MTR Melanie King and pearl
are Perfect Storm I'm the in red pill
heaven right now thank you guys for all
you do you've changed my life
um loss may sell almighty um Melanie
ain't lion 90s r b was a master class in
simping Erin
um okay I read that one already
okay one second
do dating apps make it easy to find love
no no makes it easy to find sex and says
no that's it
like no and who's responsible
for the influx the date of dating apps
the science the support let's go into
the the data the science proves it so
research has been done
um that the way the dating apps work it
is that 80 percent actually ninety
percent of the women are choosing the
top uh 10 to 20 percent of men on there
and it's usually based on looks height
and money you heard 10 to 20 I heard
five percent well they like to
they like to skew it I'm just going on
what the numbers say like if you if you
look at the research if we if we really
get into it we could probably say the
five percent that you're that's what I
believe I actually think it's lower than
that and so the women are just swiping
right swiping right swiping right the
majority of women I think the comparison
was
um uh two to a hundred in terms of
people who are in women's who swipe
right on a woman women men will swipe a
hundred and women will only swipe two so
it's like it is women own these dating
apps and a lot of dating apps with fake
women on there and some women who are on
there who look good they're actually
just selling uh their their old their of
you know I don't know if you can say the
word here I don't know if it hurts it
but like they're of or they're saying uh
go to my Instagram or go to my of or hit
me up on here or my cash app is here so
even the women who were swiping right
there's a lot of scamming and all of
these other things and a lot of men are
genuinely looking for love and again
from 18 to 30 the there is three times
the number of men who are virgins in
sexless versus women so women own these
dating apps and we're we're responsible
for the men that we're choosing we're
not giving average men a chance because
we're picking things on vanity and and
things that don't have lasting value
they dating apps are for people who want
to have sex as you said
um dating apps are not not necessarily
for people who want to find love
um I would say that love is actually
harder to find in this day and age
anyway anywhere that you go whether it
be in the club wherever it be at a bar
where would it be on data consider
Instagram a dating app and would you say
the same thing for Instagram I wouldn't
I wouldn't I would I know that when I
actually remember I actually know that
when I was single I was on Instagram and
someone dm'd me and within three hours I
was at their house oh wow so yeah I
think it's better for women who are
looking who are looking for better
quality because to me
Instagram what his is I'm not on dating
apps at all that has brought me because
people because I'm actually putting out
quality content on there so guys are
seeing my mind not just a picture of me
looking cute and just some caption that
I decided to write but they're hearing
their mind hearing the quality I'm able
to go and see what they're talking about
their friends who they actually are and
you can actually I think Instagram is a
better place to vet if you really want
to and I'm getting
hey I mean the quality is is is is is is
amazing if in my opinion as a woman
who's looking to be a wife
from a business perspective the majority
of women are not using it from a
business perspective
I want to hear from the average chick
not a girl that's got her butt all over
Instagram just like normal pictures
nothing crazy would you say that
Instagram is a good way to meet people
for women
I think the best way yeah no no the best
way to meet a person is out in the real
life we need to get out in front of
these ones and zeros
and get out into the real world and just
start to meet people here's the thing is
that from a dating app perspective it
removes being able to talk to women it
it it it it becomes completely vanity it
becomes completely how good your
photographer was it comes completely
your angles in this and that yo listen
at the end of the day women
if you want to meet good guys and guys
if you want to meet good girls you got
to do it in real life yes you know so
much of this digital ecosystem listen I
love technology at the end of the day I
utilize technology technology has
allowed me to quit my nine to five I
will forever utilize technology but I
gotta understand when does it benefit me
and then when does it not and I think
like a lot of younger people today don't
understand it because they only have
seen it with technology here I grew up
when internet was not even a thing like
I've seen life before internet and then
I see it after internet and at the end
of the day listen women gonna fall in
love with what they hear not necessarily
what they see so of course two women per
100 is going to swipe right to left of
course because what about the visual is
not as important Instagram I think is
different because let's just say all of
us all of us in here we've met through
digital we've threat through internet
like I would not know Pearl if it was
not for the internet I would not know
you I would not know Maggie I would not
know yeah so Sarah Garvey but I'm saying
there are men that I have met that I'm
able to average men you're not meaning
average Men You're meaning above average
men yeah so let's talk about not the
outliers let's talk about the majority
for the majority of people the majority
of people dating apps do not benefit
real life in person Instagram again
my dad is
if you guys DM a girl on Instagram would
you be taking her seriously or is that
more for account because because I sorry
I'll onset but I'm about to go back to
what MCO was saying is that
um most men most younger men are
socially awkward because myself maybe
Melanie maybe
yeah they don't have to talk to women
they but we grew up in a time before the
internet so we could we could socialize
with people you know and it wasn't a
thing we could talk face to face we
could start up conversations but
generally the men of today the reason
why I'm asking about you I'm asking
about you personally no I I wanted a
relationship but when you were single if
you dm'd a girl on Instagram was that
for casual or for serious it depends on
the mindset that I was in if I there was
a time when I was so you would do both
single yeah I would do both so our
Instagram could hypothetically for you
good good Avenue yeah okay same thing
yeah so um bye yes buy my specific
results now you know throughout my life
I have not been looking for a
relationship it's been with business
college since I've been in like a whole
cold-blooded relationship where I was
like okay that's my girlfriend and she
was like that's my boyfriend so
generally when I hit up women on
Instagram it is for
not relationship now but at the same
time no it don't mean that like into the
future if I was to do that in the future
it would just be vetted specifically
for not relationship but it to me at the
end of the day women need to understand
this if a guy is not ready he's not
ready
if a guy is not ready he is not ready so
so during my periods of not ready if I
hit you up what's up okay
let them know so Instagram it's either
or I'm just curious either or I would
say it depends
is also used more than just data you
know a dating app is just for
relationship sex it's about romantic
interactions Instagram it could be
business it can be like you're showing
your family your your parents
I just really want to hear from the
three guys okay so if you go I'm sorry
go ahead go ahead if you go over the
majority of what people use Instagram
for it is not a good place to find love
and stop period right there I asked for
you
but I remember making my first Instagram
when I come out and the first thing that
come to mind was I wonder how many girls
I can talk to now
straight away it was just a casual it
was nothing maybe because I was younger
I'm not too sure about how it would be
now if I was single maybe if I was
even now I think it'd only be casual for
me I don't think you could actually go
onto a dating app and try to find love
because even at the point now I was
speaking to my single friends now
and I've said you know how is your love
life going well you was out the other
night how did that go and he went oh I
went to speak to a girl and how'd that
go and he went she freaked out when she
freaked out she goes well because I
approached her it's almost got to the
point now where dating apps have
destroyed the interactions
women are now when a man approached them
who's this creep and they freak out they
really do I think maybe I could be wrong
but I think men are more open to trying
to speak to
women in public whereas I don't think
women are anymore who is more afraid of
commitment in modern dating men or women
women
they're afraid of getting hurt the
pattern of the pattern that we have
created for ourselves ultimately right
dealing with situationships things of
that sort
it one if you've been dealing with a
counterfeit so long how do you recognize
the real right and so we're afraid to
get ourselves emotionally involved and
become vulnerable and intimate with
someone because we don't know if it's a
rodeo because we don't know and we've
never been taught how to identify what
the real is so we're afraid because like
they said when men are ready men are
ready period they're committing but now
you look out and there's nothing to
commit to
hmm do you think women really can't tell
the difference between a guy who's going
to settle down and a guy who won't agree
or yeah
in this day and age especially when a
lot of the guys tell the girls up front
like she said I'm just curious out of
the guys just really quick when you guys
were in whole phase of Life did you tell
the girls absolutely I was 100 honest
this is where I'm at in life but they
always try to change you would they get
mad later yes
[Music]
I've never had a whole face angel yeah
but I agree I would I I struggle with
the term counterfeit because that
assumes that a man is presenting himself
as a husband candidate or relationship
ready I think oftentimes we see what we
want to see and we blow past what they
say and we end up hurting ourselves but
blaming it on the men
do you think that's true or false I
think that's true I was thinking in
terms of counterfeit relationships not
the men being encounter fits right
they've dealt with so many
situationships and things like that they
don't know what a real relationship
looks like right so even when a guy they
have trust issues right wait so what do
you mean they don't know what a real
relationship looks like they've never
seen a real relationship
precisely issues daddy issues trust
issues and to Camille's Point all of her
friends right she's she'll have a real
conversation with them and then two
weeks later they're talking back to the
same guy why because you know what it's
about why do you keep availing yourself
to that process why do we keep going in
these circular motions because we're
comfortable it's comfort with being hurt
right it takes something it takes some
level of vulnerability trust healing to
make ourselves available for something
new and different and because we're
unfamiliar with what that new is going
to be sometimes we're too afraid to open
ourselves up to that to explore I think
we know we just don't want what we
really should have I I think we want to
force what we want on someone else when
if we're just supposed to be in a
regular relationship we have a hard time
accepting that I think that's more of of
what it is I just I disagree that it's
um well who do you want like Prince
Charming or something I think every
every girl does I mean that's how we're
socialized but I think the problem is
like you all said we all grew up before
the internet we were able to look at Pop
Culture entertainment and say oh that's
a great show show and it ended there I
never in my wildest dreams expected that
I would be driving a luxury car in my
20s or having elaborate dates like that
was not the real world but somehow the
lines have been learned because of
culture because of moms because of
whatever and now we think what we see
out there is what we're supposed to be
living over here and 100 I don't think
women modern women today want Prince
Charming who do they want they want
Superman
they want they want they want to take
Superman and make them Clark Kent
but they just don't want Clark Kent they
want to tame Superman they want to tame
the alpha they want the alpha to want
them and only them in a monogamous
relationship and they don't want Prince
Charming off of deck I go over my
channel time and time again
good guys nice guys
petalizing them being simps giving them
the world and then they get upon they
don't want Prince Charming they want
Superman to convert him into Clark Kent
and then how often does it happen
foreign Russell Wilson There You Go
Sierra's prayer meanwhile she's still up
in the Oscars half-assed naked that's
right the nerve of you Sierra grow up
you're a mother times two or three
Savannah James look like we should be
talking about Savannah James way more
than Seattle Savannah James was the
standard on that Oscar's red carpet she
owned it it was hers she looked like a
bride all over again and I'm so proud of
her and I love her and I think she is
every woman needs to be following her
because she she's the epitome of
femininity and a wife and just being
quiet and but but but just she was
powerful it just seeing her I showed my
daughters her and I just said when I
compared her to all the other women that
was on the red carpet and my daughters
are just like they themselves I said
what do you think they said Savannah
James just looks like I mean like a
queen like like just like they they were
just like is she getting married again
like like are they renewing their vows
because she just excellence and even how
she conducts her family she is we need
to stop talking about the negativity I
think so much and focus on the women who
are doing it right because I don't think
they get enough of their flowers and
women like that who are really doing
what they should do but shout out to
Savannah James I just have to say if you
guys haven't seen her she just looks go
to her Instagram follow her if you can
for those that don't know Savannah James
LeBron James's wife she so she came up
to the Oscars with a crazy looking yeah
no crumbs no crumbs in contrast to
Russell Wilson's wife Sierra so here's
the thing and I got to do a better job
of this on my channel as well as to
continue to promote the Savannah James
continue to avoid uh uh uh promote women
such as like Alicia Keys continue to
promote women that I think would be a
fantastic example of how to demonstrate
yourself out in the public we give way
too much Credence and relevance to the
ones that they don't look they don't
clean or the ones that promote this
independent lifestyle what's so crazy is
is that if you look back to like Beyonce
who's creating Independent Women at the
same time of being married to Jay-Z
these famous women don't care about
y'all they appropriated being strong and
independent for the dollar and y'all
don't hold them accountable but y'all
hold us accountable that's your whole
Kevin accountant Yahoo Pearl accountable
Yahoo Melanie accountable Yahoo
accountable you hold Maggie The
Substitute Teacher accountable that's
who y'all hold accountable but not the
ones that lie to y'all it makes
fundamentally no sense to me it but at
the same time modern women don't hold
modern women accountable
competition
who do you think is more afraid of
commitment men or women
personally I think women women
I think
it's a strange one because both sides
can be scared of commitment but I think
in the past women wanted to be more
committed speaking to my grandparents
great grandparents they always talked
about growing up how important it was
that they found man go dancing with them
marry them settle down have kids but
these days now I think women are too
scared
for commitment because they want to be
independent and be their own boss their
own future and I don't think I think
they always get maybe too scared to rely
on a man's money these days
what what do you think who's more afraid
of commitment men or women
I think men
if you want to Define commitment as
marriage
I think men making rational decisions uh
regarding long-term commitment should be
doing so and understanding the potential
negative repercussions for choosing
incorrect if you choose the incorrect
women that'll be one of the worst
decisions that you ever make in your
life why because men feel the brunt of
making an in correct decision if you
decide on a woman who
wants the false alligate
you suffer the consequences there's no
such thing as false allegations when it
comes to man on woman
if you decide to wake up on your head
every single day and you look to the
right of you and on your pillow is a
terrorist that makes your life a living
hell you're still guilty until proven
innocent
I think at the end of the day in
understanding the negative repercussions
in the family court system
and understanding what is going to
happen to you if you're the breadwinner
with alimony
with the child
managers making rational decisions
regarding commitment but at the same
time men today have so many other
options within that and this is the
scary thing if you look in a culture
such as Japan which has a rapidly
decreasing birth rate
in the level of technology that a Japan
has actually is more than the United
States you could be in a elevator five
floors down in a parking deck and still
get cell phone reception in Japan
but they utilize technology to the point
where
you can be in Japan and they have hug
parlors
um
because men might need affection and
then they just go get a hug
to say that that will not be a reality
within our modern culture today within
America within North America within
Western cultures is not far outside the
reality and I think that's something
that has to be assessed they can buy
used panties out of a vending machine
in Japan yes use panties out of a
vending machine and they also uh is the
love dolls are the they are they are
innovating in terms of uh robotic
companionship but listen I always want
to finish the point real quick as well
if you look towards all of the forms of
entertainment that young men within
modern society today within Western
society today have they're coming up to
a real fundamental decision like bump
commitment marriage
let's just talk about dating if the
option is yo I can go over here and go
and see a Call of Duty LAN party with me
and my partners for the rest of this
Friday night and have a bang up time
shooting terrorists in the head versus
going on a date with a modern woman
today these men are making rational
decisions there are men that are making
rational decisions of should I stay in
tonight
beat off to the hub
instead of going out and deal with the
mouth of a modern woman like legit
they're making these rational decisions
and the technology today is bringing us
farther apart than closer together and
the thing is is like that's the point of
social media supposed to bring you
closer together but it's it's a foe it's
a far bringing closer together it's not
a closer together in reality and in fact
it's bringing us farther apart because
we have all of these short-term dopamine
driven
options
what do you think Melanie who's more
afraid of commitment men or women I
think men I think he's correct in terms
of who you want to talk about marriage
but if you want to talk about I I think
it's twofold I think if we're talking
about marriage it's going to be men just
because of the consequences that if it
doesn't work out and the responsibility
what it means to a man there's men and
they have very little benefits to being
married uh women have most of the
benefits to being married but I will say
this in terms of just like commitment
relationships women have more options in
terms of swiping right and they always
the hypergamy and and any they always
want something better something
something better can come along there
why would I do I want to settle with him
because uh oh who just popped in my DM
um it's it's actually
um you know and they will they they
don't want to tie themselves down
because somebody richer finer or
something will come along because it's
easier for us to just you know even
unless you're like a high level and
famous and people women Know Who You Are
are you're not flooded with DMS and
women coming after you but women even if
you're an average woman there's more men
trying to come at you and you never know
who could be around the corner and and
even the dating apps show this this is
why women just will constantly swipe
left on the majority of men that are out
there and this is supported by the data
as well it was a it was a um report that
recently came out that said that between
the ages of 18 to 30 women report being
in a in a relationship 60-ish percent of
the time meanwhile men in the same age
range Report with being in a
relationship 30 of the time
right so then the idea is is that most
women are dating older because it's not
within that specific age range or
lgbtq a right so if 20ish year old men
are going their own way
then this is something that has to be
looked at because our birth rate right
now in America is the lowest that has
been in like 40 years and we're catching
up to Japan
so we have to address these issues today
because if not you don't want to be in a
country with a rapidly declining birth
rate that's like being in a corporation
with a rapidly declining profit margin
but you don't want to be a part of that
we have to understand that those guys uh
you know those guys are actually you you
said that opting for uh video games also
opting to actually lead the country
against possible Bros right shout out to
the passport Bros right there you go so
what's happening is they America doesn't
understand and I guess women don't
understand that what they're doing is
that they're pushing their men away so
they're pushing their men away to these
other countries and then cursing them
out for going to these other countries
while pushing them away so it's it's a
it's a whole vicious cycle of what's
gone in America I actually think like
you said America's birthday is going to
get like Japan's and what's going to
happen what is going to happen is that
Americans are going to have be having
babies with other women from other
countries and America's gonna I think
we're seeing the fall of America it
actually we're seeing it in real time
wanted to say if I don't want you no one
else can have you and you see these
women it's like oh they're broken Dusty
they can't get women they can't get up
with a woman like me but that's why they
have to go there but they reject these
men treat these men like crap and then
when they go and these men and first of
all this is pride I think you're better
than a woman in another country just
because she's in another country you're
so much better than her that just shows
like you're all for women and you want
women to win but yet these women from
these other countries they're poor
they'll just get with a man for a
sandwich I mean I've just seen the most
deranged things learn from them it's
abusive why don't we learn it's like
absolutely if someone's if someone's
getting an A in the class you don't get
mad at them you take notes why are they
winning facts it's Pride we feel like we
own our men in our culture and and it's
like if I reject you and a lot of times
women are not wanting to compete if I
use the word compete with women they're
just like I don't think he should like
me for me they want they don't want you
having more options outside of what
they're giving you so like they want you
to accept their lower standards I think
that's why women shame men for having
standards is because then they don't
have to compete for a man absolutely if
we can convince him that we're the best
and we're have slept around we're
overweight we're like anything that a
guy when we're older then we don't have
to compete we don't have to bring
anything else to the table modern women
today will shame insults and modern
women today will shame insult and guilt
you out of your standards
and how can we improve if we don't even
admit there's a problem if you're
overweight the first thing you have to
do is weigh yourself but as women we
can't even weigh ourselves without
pointing at the men no
but that's that's it that's why I said
it's I really do believe like on a
deeper note I believe we're watching the
fall of a Nation right in front of our
eyes I actually believe that we're
watching The Fall of the western General
right in front of our eyes and I said
the women the way and I say that because
the women are degenerating in my
personal opinion the women are
degenerating the whole the whole society
goes to pot
um the men are now saying that they can
be women how do you know what I'm saying
so I'm saying the whole society is going
to put so we can sit here and because
for me I think it's not just
relationships that need saving
whole society
do you think looking at women you can
tell what a society looks like if you
want to see what a society looks like
you look like 100
you can look at society and and that is
why men are flying over from the West to
another country and get in play the
women from this from the West they can't
fly over somewhere else to go again man
no no absolutely
there's no way I'm dealing with that it
women cannot go we don't have the same
if if Western men can are not wanting us
and and can't deal with us we can't get
them in here men from more traditional
countries which the vast majority of the
other countries in the world are way
more traditional than the West
especially the U.S I don't know about
the UK but the the U.S if the men there
say that you're a hot mess and they're
not wifing you up you're not going to go
to Italy uh you know Portugal or or
Brazil and and get a man unless he's
trying to get a Visa I gotta I gotta
contradict that because I'm the digital
Nomad right I'm the person who's
traveling and going to these places
however I will say that I have an open
mindset that I'm going in culturally
into you guys this point I want to study
from the from the a student right I want
to understand their culture more what do
you disagree with I'm just I'm not
disagreeing I'm just providing a
different perspective of a woman you
said you disagree with that so I was
just wondering disagree with what what
part of what he said oh no no I'm I'm
following behind um Melanie here or I'm
sorry yeah with the fact of women not
being able to do that and so I'm saying
as a digital Nomad who is doing that who
has been knowing that since the pandemic
my experience has been different but
it's because I'm coming into these
cultures and I'm understanding to your
point I'm studying the a student you're
submissive nature your culture right
what are we not doing in America that we
should be doing better right because we
aren't getting it over there so that's
been my mindset so I've literally been
in Portugal I'm literally in London and
I've getting hit on from guys all the
time who are seriously wanting
relationships they're wanting marriage
and it's because I'm making friends in
these different cultures and they're
teaching me be submissive you know learn
a little bit and this is how we serve
our men this is how we cater to them
this is how we are
um you know providing that and I'm
honestly American women should be doing
it more it's life-changing it is
something real quick sorrow said
something that was incredibly important
and I just don't want to skip through it
because it was so important you said
that the direction and the way that we
are moving right now is leading to the
fall of our society that's correct and
if you think about what has been the
Cornerstone to build the west and the
Cornerstone has been hard working men
hard working men with the hard-working
man today gets no respect that's right
the sanitation worker the construction
worker
the plumber
they get no respect today and it's just
that's why on my channel I ensure that
these men get air time frequently the
oil rig workers oh [__] if you just
strip them off today our world would be
in Calamity even today
and these same exact men don't get
respect yep and the thing is I think to
myself like what why is that
the Modern Woman today has been tricked
that her education is correlated to her
intelligence or it's correlated to the
type of man that she is owed
her worth is equivalent to that yeah and
it's [__] so here here's the thing
digital nomad
would you date a blue-collar man a
hard-working man absolutely I'm dating
right now I just I mentioned that that's
my status in dating and what's he doing
he drives he's a driver he's a trucker
shout out to the truckers driver yep so
I I absolutely and not to mention just a
digital Nomad I'm a business attorney
right I went to college at 16. I
definitely have accolades but I'm not
leading that as my Forefront I didn't
come from I'm trying to be that's not
that's not what I lead with right I very
rarely even it's not that I'm hiding it
but I don't want to talk about that I
want to get to know you for you what is
your character like what are you that's
what I want to marry that's what I'm
interested in so I don't really care
what you do honestly because I my
mindset is as a woman as a wife what a
wife brings to the table honey is I'm
going to equip it and value us if you
got a dream and a mission baby I'm gonna
take that and I'm gonna flourish it I'ma
cultivate it because that's what I
believe women are purpose to do right
but do you believe that men from other
countries are looking at women in
America specifically thinking I want
that American woman absolutely not right
absolutely but I approach right I'm not
coming over there's the American girl
I'm coming over I have friends in the
culture I'm I'm in their culture I'm
immersed and now they're they're in
they're interested in me right they're
like what's different about you right
you're not the American girl you're not
who we see on TV you're not the culture
and it Sparks conversation and then they
get to see me and they're talking to me
and they're like it's something
different about her just like Camille
you can notice a unicorn in the room by
how she speaks how she talks that's how
you know a wife that's how she talks I
think the downfall of America
specifically as a Brit as one of the
only Brits I think one of the downfall
of the of Americans has been the ego and
Americans for very long have thought
that America is the world right and so
the world kind of revolves around
American it's the greatest nation not
realizing that all of this other time
the rest of the world has always existed
the the Saudi arabias I don't know the
the thailands the Philippines the the
African nations and then what's happened
is the ego has grown so big that it
started to kind of implode on itself
when it comes to America and everyone's
like
what we were trying to tell you we were
trying to tell you you need to be a
little bit more humble so it's happening
with the women specifically in America
and I love American women like I really
do I think American women are great I'm
telling but I'm saying the ego that has
been allowed to inflate itself and then
what is going to happen is the rest of
the world are actually watching and
laughing correct at the women in America
that oh my God look at these women they
literally I've seen women in America
literally have a vibratory device and
make it and make a video about how good
it is and how much better of a man that
is than a man no shame no the average
modern woman podcast they all are
sponsored by Men by women's devices I'm
just like what no other woman outside
the America would do that can I be
honest as an American woman I thought
like that and I will I will own it and
it wasn't for me and this is what I
think is happening in American culture
is that we are under this disillusion
and we have this ego and we thinking
that we're better and we're not going to
push our men away and oh I deserve to be
married and for me I personally had to
have this life Awakening and it happened
to me around 28 29 and I literally had
to stop dating for a while a season I
went to therapy I went to counseling and
I had to change how I thought and I view
things and what my positioning was and
what I needed to do differently so
Lauren wouldn't look at herself at 60
and go there you go oh I didn't take
accountability right back to our word
for the evening I didn't take
accountability and that's why I'm single
right so I had to do that and I'm now
yielding the results of that it took
some time as the garden I had to
cultivate it had to get some ground in
there and now we're seven years in and
I'm seeing the Harvest of that I'm the
men that I attract quality even though
they might not be oh top tier jobs and
things like that but their character it
sets them apart and that's what I want
is your character not necessarily your
job amen so I'm it's you did you hear
what she said she said she said take
accountability she she owned up to that
the way you just spoke and talked about
how you had to own your stuff you rarely
hear that about from women and
especially in the U.S and I think the
reason why the U.S we have such a big
head is because we own we own
entertainment and entertainment owns
culture so Hollywood music all of that
we've we've spread to the world through
that our tendrils have reached culture
we're not talking about you know
military and all that but if we want to
talk about that we own movies television
and music it's period And So It has gone
out like I remember I would go to
another country and our movies will be
on with subtitles and I'm like or I
would meet people from other countries
like oh yeah I know Fresh Prince of
Bel-Air and I'm like like you grew up
with it and they're just like yeah but
they would grow with the subtitles and I
we I used to be as American I'm just
like like what like this weird to me
like why don't you have your own but I
think it's because about in the U.S it's
all about consumption it's all about
being entertained everything is like you
know even social media we started all of
that dating apps we started all of that
because it's just our culture is just
very backwards and then we wonder why
what's wrong I mean and but it gives us
a false sense of Pride because we think
oh we're everybody wants to be like
everybody wants to be like us but we
don't realize half the stuff like people
are looking around laughing at us right
right except for China they steal
everything yeah but they still like
culturally it's like we have this Pride
which I think you should have pride in
where you're from but it's a false
bravado that's actually destructive and
it's blind Pride as well it's
destructive all right yeah sorry who do
you think's more afraid of commitment
men or women oh um I think for marriage
I think men men yeah what do you think
men or women I think it's equal but
women are afraid of commitment because
they feel like they're going to lose
their life which is a false fear men are
afraid of commitment because they fear
they're going to lose their livelihood
which is a real fear
um
men or women
I think it's 50 50 as well
um I agree with you
um that woman they want they don't want
to feel like they're missing out and
you know they don't want to feel it
depends on the culture because I was
speaking to a woman from Nigeria and she
was saying about how
her and her ex-husband before they could
get that divorce it would be loads of
family meetings and now she worries for
her children because well not
necessarily because
um you know she's the head of the family
but
if it was to be that they wanted to go
into marriage everyone would kind of be
involved like especially on the woman's
side so I think it depends on the
culture
um could you guys pick one if you have
to pick men or women
so the question was who is afraid more
of commitment
women
men men I was I had a hypothesis when I
started this that the older people in
the room would say men and the younger
people would say women because the
younger men don't know
but it didn't really cost like that
um okay I'm gonna Read Super chats
really quick and then I think we're
gonna close out the show um this was
a lot of fun guys thank you all for
coming tonight
okay
um okay Brighton um truth is truth is
lies and lies is truth um Tomo J Alpha
widows to their toys a wine cat food and
vibrators invest away boys
um sentience a hundred dollars
[Applause]
we missed you we missed you come back
um the only commitment phob is the salty
gamer who is scared to be ridiculed by
the chat as we drink those delicious
tears Melanie kudos to you for talking
about me regaining your purpose and
retaining from your Hiatus a purpose is
a Daily Commitment to yourself cheers
mate PJ I'm the high paid Blue Collar
man I'm one get a lot of respect just
not from Western women so there is an
incentive to be blue collar and import
lazy Prodigy um shout out to the real
MTR and Melanie King I'm Jacob Joseph
watch birth Gap by Stephen J Shaw to see
how low birth weight rates will bring
down the western civilization and how
childlessness hurts everyone but
especially women
Tomo J how can a man commit when only 10
percent of men play distinguish Chad and
Chad lights from 85 percent of average
sub Five Guys stop the cope if women
locked them up the rotation would not be
so effing broken um Dumbledore choosing
the wrong woman is life-ending event for
a man and and increasingly 99 of women
are choosing to make themselves the
wrong kind of women bro folt's law is
destroying men and kids Ryan the eating
Warrior it's women women are afraid to
commit because they always think a
better option is around the quarter due
to Instagram lifestyle armor born night
why do you think all of women are not
held accountable accountable for the
essay of men even young boys look up all
the cases with teachers and it will blow
your mind Lisa wives hold modern women
accountable Tomo J
U.S birth rate 1.64 NZ rate 1.61 UK
birth rate 1.56 Australia birth rate
1.58 it's fine guys men will step up
surely anyway any day now just be a
quote unquote nice guy zentians again
100 Super Chat
thank you
modern women aren't the commitment folks
since women are the more social ones
societal and cultural con contingent of
the West are more prevalent from them
but men are the beasts of Burden who
still endure smart men aren't marrying
not due to fear but due to caution see
um you can still be a nice guy with
confidence and not let your woman walk
all over you recognize the signs and
gracefully bow out when someone takes
advantage of you the sweet guy persona
never wins Brett and the chat is when
Roman Coliseum in a good way Lou Casey I
vote for making Maggie a permanent guest
see Dumbledore as a designer of social
platforms we make it to specifically
monetize women's addiction to attention
and yes Instagram is a great way it's a
gateway drug to of ghost stallion fire
Emoji Dante Bryant real life is the best
way to meet if you're a six foot Adonis
ask me mortal ask mere mortals just just
get craft us mere portals just get
crapped on cm to the credit of the girl
in the white she is definitely a seven
or higher she rates to date above
average and she is mentally sharp as
well her good logic to her don't say she
should date average Aaron cabat to me
the reason life is so complex today is
that there is a limited number of real
truths and for every truth there is a
thousand lies to follow Angel Griggs
stop evading the question can you talk
about why women don't physically react
to a husband's missive missive his
request and rebel and then get the hit
and disciplining making them the person
they are the person do as they are told
CM with dating apps women are clearly at
an advantage their egos get inflated by
them first signs of trouble
um why to fight or fix it when you can
open the app and get a new man in five
minutes Al Lynn how about you let the
white man speak his mind I am only 161
centimeters tall and my girlfriend is a
182 centimeter volleyball player I'm not
even Rich you men need to stop
complaining about these kind of tens
girls and 10 and look for 10 nice girls
no but Melanie don't mind that the
camera angle is very appealing empty MTR
um
MTR Melanie king or the per I read this
one already um Let me refresh it real
quick just to make sure there are no
other super chats also guys make sure
you like the video and subscribe to the
channel
we are trying to get more 2 million
subscribers by July so you know it's an
ambitious goal but you never know
um DL Saint I really want to know is
that Melanie king um salute to all I'll
catch the reply
I just met Jules Mari made nine figures
showing women's dark side to a public
audience The Savvy ninja the erosion of
culture and personal convictions and
shame has produced Simpson 304 and we in
the west suffer from
the blessing of affluence Patrick e one
of the best shows I have seen all are
building off of each other everyone is
valid Mrs Maggie is basing out I love it
um the downfall of America is going to
be like the 25 Universe experiment
experiment please react to it in the
future blow your mind send it to me on
Instagram just pearly things one
um truth is lies and lies is truth Tomo
J uh Alpha I read this one already okay
I also had a quick question what do you
think about people that criticize the
red pill space and say just find a nice
woman don't date those type of girls
it's naive I I think their their head is
in the sand I mean red pill exists not
because people just are delusional I
mean to say you can criticize it all you
want or disagree with it maybe that's
not your lived experience
I mean that's just my only people who
criticize it like you're invalidating
other people and saying what they're
saying or or their lived experience is
false because just maybe it's not your
reality or it may be your reality but
you're in denial so I I think what is
there to criticize if
I mean these are facts you're just
harping on the negatives of women you're
just it's a reality like put your head
in the sand or live the Disney Dream in
your mind exactly and the Disney Dream
will leave you single right that's the
delusional sense that most American West
culture women are stuck in and it's
leaving us single and so I think we are
talking and having discussions around
the red pill topic because this is the
reality that people need to deal with
it's a humbleness that needs to happen
and it's balancing but it's changed
right people don't like change it's a
different way of thinking that obviously
would make us better but people don't
want to engage or entertain those
conversations because they are they want
the norm you have internalized misogyny
my simple answer is to look at the data
just look at the data right like I used
to you know back in my corporate life I
was an internal Management Consultant
and we can't just walk into an office
after a couple of months and looking at
a particular issue in our problem and
just say that's the problem no we have
to show data we'd have to show our work
we'd have to show exactly why our
hypothesis is exactly true of what the
particular issue is just look at the
data if you look at the marriage rate if
you look at the divorce rate if you just
look at the numbers
if you just look at the numbers simply
then you should understand that there's
a burning platform for something going
wrong you look at the birth rate just
just look at the numbers
just look at the number that's it that's
it most people don't want to though most
people are about feelings uh-uh you know
so I hate what you're saying but most
people have bad feelings
they should just shut up Bliss ignorance
is more comfortable than conflict in
dealing with issues and I think we have
been pacified as people and we have not
been dealt how to properly deal with
controversy because controversy is
necessary to change things and to bring
about Evolution but because we have been
pacified with comfort and not having to
deal with it not wanting to deal with it
we don't and when people come up and
they want to deal with it it becomes a
problem you are the problem by the way
when you want to deal with it yeah any
thoughts no I can't expand on it much
more than this man just did um the
evidence is out there you just need to
look for it um
Jon Snow
now guys you can give your final
thoughts for the show I will read any
super chats that are sent before the
show ends um after they give their final
thoughts so shout on shout out any of
your channels you know give your final
thoughts now is the time start here go
around and then second row I absolutely
enjoyed my time being here
um thank you to all the panelists for
giving me the opportunity to let my
thoughts be known I appreciate you guys
I thought that we build off each other
extremely well even though some of us
have extremely different views so shout
out to each and every one of you uh I am
MTR if you look up on YouTube you put an
MTR you're gonna be able to find me in
all of my content uh mediocre tutorials
and reviews it's a pleasure to be doing
content for this amount of time and
still be here pumping out content each
and every day last but not least Pearl
thank you it's been dope to watch it
rise it's been dope to watch the way you
continue to move throughout this space
with degree of Elegance outside of
different detractors or haters I know
you behind scenes and behind scenes you
were just as sweet as you are on camera
so shout out to you Pearl
yeah I would say the same thing is I I'm
just amazed by it and I I think more
than anything I'm just so impressed by
Pearl and her mind and and what she's
created and I it just feels I just love
meeting every single one of you guys
like hearing the opinions and things and
it and it just is it's so inspiring
um and so I'm just grateful that for the
experience
look me up melon okay that's it uh thank
you for having me again Poe and we've
been doing this for a long time now
um anyone that wants to
um follow me you can find me at Sarah
Garvey that's sa space r a Garvey
um I want to thank comedy
want to thank Maggie want to thank MTR
um Welcome To My City
um I don't know how you feel about it
but um yeah welcome to it and thank you
all for joining and thank you all for
listening yeah and I will say I watched
all three of you guys before I've even
like really did YouTube so it's kind of
cool to have like a 360 where I could
actually talk to the people I used to
watch on YouTube so you guys all
inspired some of the stuff that I made
it's a pleasant uh Absolutely I'll start
by thanking you Pearl for the invitation
so happy to be across the pond really
impressed with all the work that you're
doing and the cooking that you're doing
so I am Maggie The Substitute Teacher I
have three YouTube channels I have a
cooking channel where I stream everyday
family meals and healthy meals teachable
moments with Maggie is my second Channel
I've been on an etiquette and elegance
journey and I share there twice a month
what I've learned and then I also have a
third Channel called the Wives Club
which was created by the late great
Kevin Samuels because I didn't have a
community of like-minded and
marriage-minded women so I asked his
permission to create one and that's what
we do there once a week
um I'd like to say thank you to all of
you it was amazing meeting all of you
and hearing your views and your
perspectives
um you can find me on socials
k-a-m-i-l-e-s-h-a-n-t-a-y Kimo Shantae
on those facials thanks
wow I am um I didn't know I was in the
presence of so many Greeks in this room
so I'm just
overwhelmed right now um but seriously
no I have in um enjoyed this
conversation thoroughly even the
different points of views I'm of the the
sound mind that different points of
views can actually yield perspective so
thank you all for yielding your
intelligence your brains your
perspective Pearl thank you for hosting
this I seriously did not know what this
was about a friend shared you and I just
kind of followed along and so I'm gonna
follow all of you guys and all of this
awesomeness because I didn't know who I
was in the room with so I'm just honored
to be here
um Lauren a Morgan Esquire that's me on
all platforms
you know um thank the opportunity pal
I'll come here to learn mainly I'm quite
new to all of this and I'm definitely
going to be driving home with a lot of
information it's stored in my head
um but
I think channels like you are extremely
important and I think more people do
need to listen
um to get the different perspectives in
life I think is the only way people will
grow and move forward
um so Chan underscore Robson on
Instagram and go and check out something
strange apparel online
okay thank you guys all for coming
um okay a couple announcements before we
end the show first I'm going to read the
super chats um guys like the video on
your way out
um that is the most important metric
that YouTube uses to push out these
streams so if you want to share these
streams if you think we do a good job
here make sure you like the video a like
is free I know not everyone can Super
Chat you know I watch for free on
YouTube all the time so I don't blame
you but you know a like that's free okay
ATA High Pearl did you ever review uh
Patrice O'Neil shark Theory I don't
think so follow me uh Pearl did you ever
have the ante makeover with the big wig
makeup and long lashes I saw it in one
of your videos earlier
no I've never done that one uh dally
um a hundred dollar Super Chat
bowler old fart married 33 years much
respect for the dialogue you're carrying
forward
um Illuminating much love Russ great
show today great panel I'm Bryant
numbers on easy and our numbers and
money MTR
follow me women women will get hurt and
are unable to heal if because if they
avoid accountability of the bad choice
I've seen they'll instead lash out in
comfortable groups of other women who
refuse to heal as well sentience pearls
Pearl please articulate yourself into
reading the English language correctly I
bet she says this incorrectly I might
have I don't know
[Laughter]
um DLC um is that Melanie King salute to
all I'll catch the replay
um I am just Jules and then I read that
one already let me just refresh it real
quick to make sure there are not any
others guys a couple announcements
before we close out the show uh shaisha
Nolan we need solutions to the problems
not just conversations
uh okay I read them all okay a couple
announcements we have two clips channels
just pearly clips and pearl daily make
sure you go subscribe to both we are
doing our first meet up so if you want
more information on the Meetup where
what are we what we are going to be
doing and where it's at
um it is in downtown London make sure
you sign up to our Google form it's
going to be Sunday at 5 30 in downtown
London so sign up to our Google form to
be notified about the event also guys we
have four membership tiers the first you
get to be a part of the chat the second
Discord and blogs third connect with me
on social media fourth a one-on-one call
with me once a month um this is for
people that want to improve on YouTube
also guys um subscribe to Wife School
Melanie is going to be doing a fashion
episode with me soon
um also Maggie taught me how to cook
this week that should come out in the
next like two weeks ish
uh animation Channel just pearly
animations go follow that go follow my
two talents guys we're we're a network
now so Auntie Jenny and uh King riches
make sure you go subscribe to both uh
King rich is almost a 70k he's been
working so hard so make sure you go
subscribe to that
um also guys we have one official
pregame Instagram none of the other ones
are us go follow my Instagram just
pearly things one and go follow my Tick
Tock justperlythings.5 thank you so much
for watching and I will talk to you next
time
yes
foreign